uh good evening uh everybody and welcome
to
members and officers
to this planning meeting of the 20th of
october as always a little bit of
housekeeping if i may
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs
uh the way you
if you use the lift there are stairs at
that end also to the door on my right to
your
left
please assemble on hawley square green
and an officer will come over to
bring you back in
if that is necessary
uh could i ask if anybody intends
filming this meeting this evening
no okay thank you very much
um
also i would ask you that
not to use mobile phones turn them to
silent and please do not make phone
calls
or take phone calls during the meeting
i've said this at a few meetings
members and to members of the public
we get quite a few
requests from members of the public
about planning applications
i don't want anybody to think that we
ignore them
there are rules and regulations about us
answering them in different ways
i'm not saying that we shouldn't just
say to you we've accepted them
but please don't think they've been
ignored i'm speaking as myself and i'm
sure i'm speaking of
with members of the committee here this
evening and of course officers
thank you
members requesting to speak under 20.1
any members wishing to speak 10.1
nope i don't see any
public speaking this evening uh the
following applications have been
reserved for public speaking for members
please note
the following items on the agenda
item 5a 22 dangcore gardens brawl says
item 5d
91 botany road broadcast
item 5 f
ws cold and sun 116 moncton street
moncton
and item 5 g
land rear of 92 to 102 moncton
street
moncton
i have two points of information would
members please note that agenda item 5c
harbour amenities at the east cross wall
at ramsgate has tonight been withdrawn
from your agenda
also another point of information i'll
hand over to mr livingston the planning
applications manager
thank you chair um two points of
information first one on agenda item 5f
which is 116 moncton street
the description of development is
updated to more accurately reflect the
enlargement of the existing storage
building
to a single story retail unit currently
the description reads a change of use of
the existing
structure and so now the description of
this part of the description on that
application is updated to read change of
use and enlargement of existing storage
building to a single story retail unit
another point of information for members
on a gender item 5g land the rear of 92
202 moncton street
subsequent to the publishing of the
planning committee schedule
the received legal agreement to secure
the proposed planning obligations
including affordable housing and
financial contributions has been
ratified and sealed by the council now
this means that the recommendation on a
gender item
5g
sorry an item 5g is changed from the
recommendation being defer and delegate
to officers to approve subject to
receipt of a legal agreement and
safeguarding conditions and that is
changed to approve subject to the stated
conditions thank you chair
thank you ian
agenda item one apologies for absence i
have received apologies from councillor
rozewski
and councilman hart
uh any other apologies please
counselor robin
any other apologies at all
no no substitutes
sorry it's cancer shonk cancer shank is
substituting for counsellor heart
thank you very much
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
thank you and for members
council kane obviously has declared that
interest
when we come to that item council keen
will be asked to leave the chamber
uh councillor shonk
i just had an interest i do know the
coal family in montgomery
thank you i will take advice on that
counselor strong to see whether you have
to leave
i think a lot of people do know the
whole family of mr moncton
i'll take advice on that when we come to
that
thank you
the general item three the minutes of
the planning committee which was held on
the 15th of september do members agree
that the minutes of that planning
committee
which was held on the 15th of september
2021 be approved and signed by myself
uh could i have a proposal please
councillor coleman cook
uh second please
counselor right several there uh do
members agree
that i signed those as correct
thank you very much
general item for
the garden center monte ferrari avenue
ramsgate i've asked the planning office
now
which i believe oh mr manson please
do outline very bold
thank you chair um
this is the application for a
warehouse with canopy for the use um for
the garden center at ramsgate on monty
fury avenue members visited it a few
weeks ago on friday
and we looked at the service yard where
the proposal is is due to be
constructed and so
the application site is outlined in red
on the screen
the particular area
that this application is in is currently
used for open storage as mentioned so
it's the area where
the mouse is at the south of the parking
area
and this is the
proposed footprint of the warehouse
so the
proposal is for the use of this
warehouse for storage of our season
goods fixes and fittings and various um
elements of things that are currently
stored in a trailer which
there is a photo of from the site visit
here
um so it's currently parked storing a
number of goods
for the garden center
members looked inside the storage area
and considered the arrangements in terms
of vehicles moving in and out of that
current area used for in part deliveries
but predominantly
for the storage of various
products for the garden center
in terms of the relationship with the
neighbouring properties the proposal
this photo is showing the rear of
properties in muir road
this is a view towards properties on
brendell grove
um where currently you'll see that the
waste is stored
and then this is
towards the the back of the
back of the garden center towards
properties on houston road
so in terms of the relationship with the
neighbouring properties the proposal
there's an 18.5 separation distance with
the properties on muir road
the proposal originally when it was
submitted in the previous application um
was refused for being too high and
therefore to imposing on the residency
in causing a sense of enclosure it was
reduced by 2.5 metres um in this current
application
so it's four meters to the eaves height
this is the proposed south elevation
to the right hand side of the image you
can see there's a level change to the
properties on
brindle grove with a canopy that means
that the roof is pitching away from the
properties
on that on that uh that road
then you have this elevation which if
you were to go into the yard area and
turn left this is what you would be
addressed with
um and then this is the rear elevations
are facing towards the car park just to
again show that the property or the
proposal is pitching away from the the
boundary with the brindle grove
properties
so as as mentioned the brindle
properties are on the right hand side of
the image and muir road
at the bottom here so as i mentioned the
proposal is for
the storage use of this warehouse
structure there is a condition which is
proposed to link it to the use of the
garden center so it couldn't be used for
an independent business
or commercial entity
concerns on site were raised about how
it may impact on
sunday trading hours as well as the
issues that were talked about in the
last meeting about when deliveries could
occur to the site
as mentioned in the previous meeting
there is there are no existing
restrictions on when deliveries can
occur for the garden center what's being
proposed in this application is
deliveries occurring from 7am
to
all the use of the warehouse from 7am
onwards
and another query that came up both on
site and in the meeting was about how
deliveries actually occur is there
sufficient turning for vehicles in this
yard given that there's now going to be
a you know this storage building here um
vehicles are able using the car park
area to reverse into that yard
and in fact members will recall that one
actually occurred when we were present
on the site visit
so overall we consider as officers that
the previous uh issues for the
application that was refused have been
resolved
and therefore subject to conditions uh
the development is um recommended for
approval thank you
thank you ann
i move the officers
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please second
thank you councillor coleman cook
all right your miles away there um
members do you wish to debate at all
i will just say if i may um
there's be no
site visits are
around about nine o'clock on a friday
morning normally
and i also understand that it's
difficult for some people to get along
because of work and so on but um
obviously the site visit did go ahead
can't stop with them
thank you chair um just two updates uh
councillor moore and myself have uh
received a letter from
the british garden center the developer
about this this afternoon uh following a
meeting that they they you know they're
very forthcoming and speaking to
residents and that was helpful and just
on the they have made a couple of um
concessions or suggestions one about the
um
the opening hours they've actually
they've said that they would be happy in
this letter to us to
uh
restrict
the use of it from 8am to 6pm
um and they've also said that um
they are happy to keep consulting with
residents about the um the painting of
the the warehouse and the colour of it
um
so i don't know i mean i don't know if
there's provision for if that could be
um
you know if the panel is minded to uh
accept this but if that could be
and put in as a condition
um of of consent if panel is minded is
to give it consent
um
yeah i mean there are still concerns of
residents about uh the noise one
resident has said to me that uh
there's
the the they feel there's been there
hasn't been a um an independent review
carried out of noise
um
uh
you know effects of this
i wonder if uh
officers can vote if that's the case or
not and if it's not the case if that's
something which could still be
considered
thank you chair um so on to the first
point the
what's proposed at the moment in front
of members in terms of the motion is for
um deliveries to be restricted or use of
the premises
restricted to um
the hours of seven till six monday to
sunday obviously we received a copy of
the letter that was sent earlier today
which indicates that um that they the
applicant was prepared to accept a
condition if considered appropriate by
the planning committee for deliveries to
occur from 8am to 6pm so there's a
difference there between use of the
building and obviously deliveries
because obviously maybe someone accesses
the building to move stuff around
if members felt that
that condition in terms of deliveries
to the warehouse was necessary to be
restricted then um the motion would need
to be amended
and that condition would need to be sort
of built into the motion um which would
need both the chair and vice chair to
agree to withdraw the current motion to
amend it and put it back in front of
members um in terms of the second point
with regards to the impact from noise
and disturbance there is no um noise
impact assessment that's been carried
out for the proposed development
predominantly that's because the
existing relationship
um is considered to be
to create a level of background noise
from the fact that it's an open storage
yard clearly in use with deliveries in
the open and therefore that it's the
proposed warehouse doesn't make the
situation any worse there are arguments
about whether or not it makes it better
and obviously that's something that was
discussed last month about whether or
not there could be
vibrations etc within that could cause
an impact
or indeed that whether or not you've in
some form of insulation that would come
with the panels that would be used would
insulate it but there's certainly no in
our view no worsening of the existing
impact from the fact that you've got an
open storage use there at the moment
which is clearly operating in in close
proximity to two neighbours
uh thank you for that ian um
members um is there any more comment
before i got this to the vote
i will say this to
members of the public i know committee
members know this but when i have a chat
as chair
to an officer
um
it has been noticed uh i get advice and
that's all it is and i think any chair
of any committee
there has been some comments in previous
meetings and i just wanted to make that
clear i get advice
which any member of this committee can
get so
that's the reason we chat thank you
so just to come back to what council
hopkins has mentioned
um if there is agreement with the chair
and the vice chair to withdraw the
motion um then if a new motion was put
forward um you know to uh to add a
condition it would we would still retain
the existing condition which is the use
couldn't occur it could occur between
seven and six but for delivery
specifically for that unit
it's from eight to six and it's that
unit i think this is an important point
it's only to that unit because that's
all that we're actually considering it's
not the garden center because they could
have other deliveries at the moment it's
just to this unit
uh thank you in um
you've heard that uh
members um
i'm going to put this to you
when i say to withdrawal yes
so
you've heard what uh our office has
mentioned that
i agreed to withdraw this motion i would
like the uh vice chair
to second
second nature
thank you and members you agree
okay and we
uh come back to ian again so just a
choice sorry about this just just for
absolute clarity um so um then put
forward a motion which would need to be
forwarded and seconded by chair and vice
chair
to move for approval of the conditions
as outlined plus a condition restricting
uh deliveries to that unit between eight
and six pm
thank you uh i think members understand
what mr livingston has said there
um i do propose that and i'd like the
vice chair to
second i'll second that uh members if
you're happy with that uh
new
would you please show your hand please
approval
against
abstentions
thank you members that has been carried
thank you for that
moving on to agenda item five the
schedule of planning applications and
public speaking
any site visits will take place
for committee members on this is a good
day on the 5th of november
2021 which uh i believe is a friday
uh so agenda item 5a is the planned
application for approval for 22
dangcourt gardens brewsters
uh speaking in favor of the application
is mr bragg is mr bragg with us this
evening thank you mr bragg you have
three minutes and if you push a button
on the mic please
thank you chairman and members of the
committee my name is daniel from sc
architecture we're the agent for this
application and speaking to you now on
behalf of the applicant
as you are aware this application
concerns an extension and redevelopment
of an existing detached dwelling to a
good size three to four bedroom family
home
something that we are all seeing more
and more of in recent years
we have worked hard with the applicant
and the case officer for several months
to find solutions
that are acceptable
solutions that address and overcome all
of the objections received for this
application
the applicants have already made
numerous compromises to the design
including removing parts of the first
floor accommodation removing and
obscuring certain windows and lowering
the proposed roofline to reduce the
overall scale
the scheme now in front of you is the
end result and we hope will create a
fantastic home for the applicants and
their children to enjoy
the applicants are a young family and
never anticipated anything like the
opposition they have faced to their
application
which has been noted within the redacted
objections on the council website
it has unfortunately become a difficult
and upsetting experience for them but
one that we all soon hope will be
worthwhile
the various objections received appear
to be based on a general dislike of the
scheme with very few valid planning
reasons
the crux of these objections appears to
be the introduction of first floor
development and a fear that this
proposal will change the character of
the area for the worse
the applicants purchased this property
last year having found a road and an
area they liked and seeing a house with
potential
they saw this building work sorry they
saw the building work completed at the
next door house number 23 and used this
as an inspiration to plan the
transformation of their own bungalow
number 23 was granted permission to
extend vertically without any objections
and now appears uniquely different to
every other house in the area
this has certainly opened up an
opportunity to be creative and do
something similar with the applicant's
site
furthermore other examples of first
floor accommodation have sprung up on
the road
a similar scheme to the proposed is
currently under construction at number
61
and another planning application is
under consideration a few doors along at
number 18
suggesting that the perception of this
area as small bungalows is outdated
indeed the planners themselves highlight
that there are no planning policy
objections to the addition of first
floor accommodation to bungalows
the case officer is satisfied that the
setback position of the house
and separation that exists to the
surrounding properties means the
proposed extensions would not cause harm
to the living conditions of the
neighbours
the officer also acknowledges that the
large portions of the proposal are
almost permitted development anyway
increasing the original dwelling is by
no means an overdevelopment of the site
as this is a wide and excellent sized
plot here
which will still retain a large garden
to the rear and an equally large
driveway area at the front capable of
accommodating four cars
so to highlight and put things into
perspective
with the proposed extensions the total
footprint of the house and garage will
be 147 square meters
by comparison the extended footprint of
the next door house and garage at number
23
is actually larger at 174 square meters
the planners conclude that no material
harm would be caused to the character or
appearance of the area and we believe
that says it all
we trust you will agree with their
conclusion thank you for listening
uh thank you very much mr bank raising
points of concern is ms wood
if ms wood is there
mr chairman members of the committee we
find the report in favor of the
approving this application to be
contradictory lack of neutrality and
sometimes inaccurate all measurements
contained within the report are
approximate plus the small print on the
plans clearly states do not scale from
the drawings the report states that
dangcore gardens comprises predominantly
of detached bungalows and shelley
bungalows giving the impression that
there is a variety of property types and
as many shelley bungalows as bungalows
in fact the era comprises almost totally
of bungalows we disagree entirely
therefore that the proposed development
is generally in keeping with the area
especially as in any case it resembles
more a large house than a shelley
bungalow
the report repeatedly fails to make the
distinction between permitted
development and that requires planning
permission using inappropriate examples
of permissible development to justify
this approval of this application such
as referring to the proposed 5.3 metre
high wall along the boundary line of
number 23 as having a similar impact or
3 meter high single storage garage that
is allowed under permissible development
we would argue that there is a great
difference between the two in terms of
enclosure overbearing impact loss of
outlook and light
since the plans have been amended and
now no longer require accommodation
above the garage we would ask why the
garage could not be of a flat roof
construction and built to a standard
garage size
the author goes on to compare the
construction of a dormer winder as
having a similar level of overlooking
and reduction of privacy as a first
floor extension we feel the all fours
again grossly underestimated the
difference between the two
according to the quoted fanuc local plan
new development must not lead to
overlooking our loss of privacy and yet
in this new development has indeed
recognized the report would result in
both this may be acceptable on a housing
estate as seemly implied in the report
but it is both in congress and
unacceptable and an essentially bungalow
estate the area along the boundary line
of number 23 is not a driveway as stated
in the report it is in fact a kitchen
garden and moreover the only private
amenity space available to this property
both broadstairs town council and the
borders society as well as neighbours
have strongly opposed this application
and we entreat the committee to consider
their comments tdc recently refused
permission to build a shelley bungalow
on the opposite side of the road which
would have been over development and
outer character the application to build
free detached houses in the lane to the
northwestern side of danecourt gardens
was also refused by tdc just last year
with one factor being that they were out
to keep them with adjacent bungalows we
believe that the same compelling reasons
for refusal should be applied in this
case and ask the committee to vote
against approval or in the very least to
defer until a new review of the
application can be made
what is clearly a four-bedroom
development is being submitted under the
guise of a two-bedroom shallow bungalow
excluding the garage they are increasing
the living space from 74 square meters
to 167 square meters which is clearly
over development
uh thank you very much uh miss wood i
will not ask the uh planning officer
jason to outline the report
thank you chair
the application site is outlined in red
the proposal is for a roof extension
front and rear door windows
with an increase in ridge height and
front and side extensions so the main
issues with consideration by members are
the impact on the character appearance
of the area and the impact on the living
conditions of neighbouring properties
so this is an aerial image years ago of
the site so the property in question is
uh in the center of the image
um so you can see this is formed uh this
is a property that's within the dane
court gardens
estate
to take some other angles just to show a
bit of a wider angle context
you can see the fact that
predominantly that all the properties in
this area are single story with
bungalows
there are some properties that have uh
extended at the rear in terms of dorm
windows including the one at the end of
this particular cul-de-sac and there are
some specific examples of two-story
properties well chalet bungalows with
with normal windows at first floor um
towards the uh the eastern extent of the
estate but predominantly uh they are
single story bungalows there are
variations in design you can see from
the the roof forms so you've got some
with gay blends some with hip hip roofs
then just moving around
you can see in a bit more detail the
fact that the existing bungalow the
number 20 has
done a rear normal window at some point
you can also see the property in
question here
in the center of the image
so you have number 21
which is to the west but obviously to
the sort of close to the bottom of this
image
and and 23
you can see the sighting of the the
dwellings is slightly different it's
slightly staggered
in comparison to the application site
so this is the property at the moment
then if we look to the left-hand side
which is number 21 so that's the
property that's obviously set back from
the front building line of number 22.
and then just going to show you the
existing bit of the existing
relationship
with number 23
so
this is the design of number 23 which
was extended a few years ago
and so this is the existing relationship
with the neighbor at number 23 so
mentioned in the public speaking is the
garden area that's behind where the car
is parked here so it's between uh the
other side of this fence and the main
sidewall of the property we'll have a
little look at that relationship in a
little bit um so you've got a garden
area there
you've got the existing bungalows set
off with a garage at the back
so just looking at the opposite side of
the road you can see that you've got
bungalows on opposite side of the road
but you can see there's actually a
change in levels indeed there's a change
in level across most of the estate with
some being some further up a hill
and these properties are obviously set
up from the street level uh opposite
with again you've got a hipped roof
there
a gay blend roof and then a gable end
frontage on those properties
so the rear of the application
property
you currently have that change in level
in effect
where you've got some stairs down from
the existing ground floor this is the
rear roof slope which we'll talk about
when looking at the proposed rear door
window
then looking to number 21 so that's the
property that's set back and you can see
that set back when looking at the side
elevation of that property
at the moment
this is looking down the garden towards
number 24 which is at the rear so you
can see that the the garden is is
perpendicular to the garden of the
application site number 22
and then turning to the right
and looking towards the side elevation
of number 23 the neighboring property
you've also got a garage here which is
on the application site which is
proposed to be demolished as part of the
application
and you can see that at the moment the
rear of of number 23
protrudes past the rear of of number 22.
so the proposal as mentioned would
increase the footprint of the
existing bungalow with front extensions
as well as a side extension with the
new roof
effectively wrapping over those
extensions there is also a proposed
decking area to the rear which has
previously had planned consent
so this is the existing property that
we've seen in the images
this is the proposal the existing
properties
outline is in red the red dotted line
um so what's happening here and we'll
see this on the side elevation is that
you can see the roof uh at first floor
is pitching away
the roof pitch is staying the same as
existing but that pitch is coming closer
to the road so we'll see that on the
side elevations
you can also see the mentioned garage in
terms of the roof of that garage which
has been reduced in height from the
previously submitted scheme when the
application first came in but still does
have that roof which has been mentioned
in in in speeches
so they're looking at the side elevation
so this is the side elevation
that faces number 23
so the moment you've got these um sort
of higher level windows that are in
there at the moment so what's being
proposed and we'll see where the roof
pitch goes so roof pitch is the same
pitch
but the roof pitch starts from a closer
point to the road which would be on the
left of the image so you can see that
you've got then the the side door
windows sorry the front door window and
this and the rear door window
as well as the barn hip design
so the materials that are proposed are
for a glace lake roof so it's grey
cedric weatherboarding on the actual uh
dorm windows themselves and white smooth
render below so the materials aren't
considered to be
uncharacteristic of the area given that
there are cladding examples in the
vicinity
and there are changes in roof tiles in
and around the the overall estate so the
materials are considered to to be um
acceptable
just to look at that relationship with
the neighbor then what is occurring is
an increase in the scale of the property
directly adjacent to the boundary to
number 23 um so if the height of the
eaves at the moment which is obviously
set away from the boundary he's about
2.8 meters from the ground level on that
property
so that
effectively
would move closer to the neighboring
property on the boundary but then that
height would increase from 2.8 meters at
the eaves height
up to the eaves height of the barn hip
to 4.6 meters
and so this is one of the main impact
considerations that that's gone into the
report in terms of what's the impact on
on that neighbor so you can see that
there are windows that are discussed in
the report on the side elevation so
these windows currently obviously look
towards the the side fence of number 32
these windows from the previous planning
application has stated to serve a
bathroom and a bedroom so it's a
bathroom and a habitable room
and so the officers report has looked at
um the the question about what would be
public development and obviously this
development will allow for an eave type
of a side extension up to three meters
so there is an increase over what will
be allowed through permitted development
from this it is considered though there
is obviously limited outlook from these
windows at the moment obviously they are
side windows which are considered
different from
front and rear windows in terms of what
you would expect to find in terms of the
outlook um but that that impact is
certainly a consideration for members to
look at it's been considered by officers
that given
that there is a permitted development
fallback not to the same extent and also
given the existing relationship that
this relationship is acceptable
um in terms of looking at the other side
elevation um you've got this is the the
view at the moment facing number 21
that again would increase in the same
way so you can see that the roof pitch
is the same but it just pitches to a
higher point so the increase in ridge
height is is about one meter
with then obviously as i said the door
windows at the front so the windows the
ground floor will not change
on that um that side elation
so in terms of the increase in footprint
of the the property um it's not
considered by
officers that the scale of the footprint
is is out of keeping with the scale of
development in the vicinity um and you
can see as well in terms of the impact
from the decking of the rear um where
it's sighted does not result in our view
as a to a significant loss in privacy of
the neighboring properties from any
overlooking created
um one of the other relationships that's
really important to consider is the
impact on the neighbours to the rear
number 24
because in the rear elevation at the
moment obviously you've got the the
image that we saw earlier
with the roof slope and what's being
proposed here is i've seen an
enlargement and you can see that the
dotted red lines as well as then there's
the dormal window that's being inserted
to the rear
now
within the existing roof slope there
would be the potential to have a smaller
door window within that existing roof
slope and obviously this is visible from
a property further down at number 20
which has the same pitch um and has put
in a rear door window
now it's noted that this storm wind is
easy as you can see larger than what you
would accommodate within the existing
roof slope and obviously has likely
you know
more he's obviously got two two windows
either end uh both serving bedrooms and
a bathroom window in the center
so we've looked at the again the
permitted development fallback of what
could be done at the moment and there is
within permits development the ability
to create a rear door which would have
an impact on the neighboring property to
the rear and if i go back you can see
that you've got the rear garden of that
neighboring property there
so
if we move through the floor plans and
then show you the roof plan and you can
see how big that dormer is and we can
talk about the relationship with the
neighbor a bit more
so this is the existing floor plan of
the property
and this is what's being proposed so you
have on the ground floor on the left
hand side image
you have the garage on the side and then
upstairs you have two bedrooms so either
side two bedrooms and then a bathroom in
the center
um so in terms of then that roof plan um
you've got then the rear door window as
shown so that rear door window is 12
meters to the boundary at the rear
um and so this has um
led to the report obviously considering
that that point about the fallback
decision and therefore there will be an
impact from this proposal on that
neighbor to the rear
but
there is a
distinct possibility and weight to be
given to the fallback position which
could create a dorm window there without
needing planning permission to create a
similar relationship
with regards to windows looking into
that neighboring property at the rear
now
in terms of then other issues to do with
um the
scale of development um
it is considered that
there are variations in the style of
bungalows in the area we've looked at
the the photos that show hip truth
properties gable and properties
and
officers don't consider that the the
fact that there is a front door window
is significantly out of character with
the wider error to cause harm it's not
overly visible as a property it's
obviously down a cul-de-sac and
therefore it's not a prominent position
within this state
mentions been made of developments in
the vicinity specifically the
development next to this estate which is
the site on green sleeves in that
instance they were they were two-story
properties and that's two-story
properties to the eaves which was a
point that the inspector pointed out
about the difference between
this estate and single story buildings
and obviously the full two stories
so we don't consider that the shallow
bungalow style that's been proposed is
out of keeping with the area there is
variety
and and nor is the scale considered to
be cramped and congested
the impact on the neighbours has been
considered
and but weight has been given to the
permitted development fallback
as well as the specific existing
relationships
it is a balanced case but on balance
officers have considered that the
application should be approved and
that's the recommendation thank you
chair
uh thank you very much ian um i knew the
office's recommendation is adopted
because the vice chair please second
second nature i think house of common
cook members
calzo keen
thank you chair and i just wanted a bit
of clarification
so
the roof of the garage that was going to
be a habitable space but now
then it's not it's just a roof
in which case
why isn't it more reduced
um so it has been reduced in terms of
the accommodation or storage areas that
have been reduced in that so
obviously a request was made to lessen
that in terms of the impact on the
character appearance of the area rather
than have the full width of the property
taken up by a ridge height that's as
high as it is obviously what's then been
proposed is to reduce it by the extent
that's been put forward so
we've considered it on the merits of
what's been put forward in terms of the
rationale behind that particular point
of design that's that's the you know
that's the the application that's been
submitted all the plans have been
submitted
it is obviously a consideration by
members as to whether or not the the
overall scale including that element of
the roof is acceptable as well as also
the impact on the neighboring properties
which is the the main thing to look at
for
that uh thank you again kelsey garner
thank you yeah um thank you thank you
for the report um yeah i'm familiar with
this estate with this bungalow estate um
in fact it's in my board and i did call
this in because of the number of the
concerns that were shared about
um this
application
um
i think
calling it a
chalet bungalow a chalet um
extension is pushing it slightly
um it does
does look like a two-story house to me
um
but um i think one of my main concerns
one of the main concerns of the
broadstairs town council and the society
mentioned that this is
a bungalow estate and it's it was formed
bungalow estate you mentioned um
greensley
the green sleeves um decision that was
rejected by
yourselves when went to the planning
inspector the plan inspector upheld that
rejection and in fact our recent
training course you you mentioned that
and one of the things the inspector said
was that um he upheld it because it was
odds with the adjacent bungalow estate
um so it's recognized as a bungalow
estate and
i think it's important that it should
stay as a bungalow estate um
i know there have been a number of
dormers you mentioned installed in some
of the other bungalows but they still
remain
bungalows such was this i think would be
um
looking at it is more or less turned
into a house so i think that's my main
concern
thank you thank you
any other members which
how's the job here
thank you chair
yes i do agree with a lot of the
comments that um councillor ghana's made
i
i can't see this as a shallow bungalow
um i think the increase in footprint is
considerable
as is the bulk and scale of the
development
um
i understand the comments about
permitted development but then
why not stick to what is permitted
development i personally
feel that this is out of keeping with
the area
thank you
thank you councillor paul moore
yes thank you chair um just to reaffirm
what both councillor bayford and
councillor garner said they've covered
all my points so i'm not in favor of
this thank you
uh thank you councillor shonk
i might leave your mansion but i do know
the area it is bungalows always has been
bungalow so i know there's some
deviations but i think we must really
think about bullshit's council was their
society
and i think it's overload
i think it's an impact on the
neighborhood and that will keep them in
the area
people live here i don't know how many
objections you had
it is a concern
it is a lovely area
all bungalows mainly
that's my concern
thank you coming back council again
thank you um
i just think i agree there's lots of
bungalows there but there is a house or
a higher building right next door so i'm
kind of not seeing the difference there
is a variation in this area
thank you
do i see any other members
before i put this to the vote
okay members thank you for your input
there so i am putting this to the vote
uh for those in favor of this
application would they please raise
their hands
those against
abstentions
that has fallen
right i will turn to mr
thank you chair um so what's been
clearly outlined by members is a concern
about the the scale and design of the
proposal um
in terms of uh potentially moving a
motion on that basis um
we would
recommend in the given the debate that
it's the issue is with regards to
the
the scale and design
would appear dominant out of keeping
with the predominant form of development
resulting in significant harm to the
character and appearance of the area
and the particular policy in this
instance is policy qd02 which is the
character appearance policy as well as
the relevant broad stairs neighborhood
plan policy as well
uh thank you ian
so therefore
i put that to you members
you'd have to move no i will propose
that could i have a second please
and you understand obviously so members
you've heard
what mr vincent has said do you accept
that term from the show of hands please
and those against
abstentions
[Music]
that has been carried that has been
refused thank you
uh moving on again to the gender item 5d
which is the planned application for
refusal of 91 botany road abroad says
uh speaking in favor of the application
is ms gibson
if you're there
you have three minutes thank you
and good evening councillors firstly i
want to say thank you for taking the
time to hear me speak and also to
discuss our application
um this application i also want to
introduce my sister just and she's ready
to jump in because i get a bit upset
when i talk about this um this
application is one that's that's filled
me with great heartache and upset um and
seems to have overshadowed quite a lot
of what should be joyful things in the
last three years
the day my second child was born and i
had an inspector
the very day there having a look at the
dormer
and it feels like it's just due to my
naivety being a teacher not a property
developer and never having done anything
like this before that has led to us now
being in a situation where we're having
to appeal for retrospective planning
three years ago we started building on
our home
um a home that i bought from my
father-in-law that was my husband's
childhood home and one we wanted to be
for our forever home and it became
apparent that the architectural drawings
were inaccurate and the building
inspector said that it would be okay for
us to make the dormer slightly larger
we continued building in our ignorance
unaware of the fatal error that we were
making and
unfortunately we then had further
problems and the roof had afforded us to
5 000 pounds and in the interest um
of being respectful and transparent with
the council i applied for a change of
condition because it was november and
our home was exposed to the elements
and unfortunately um that was too little
too late and all of our ceilings fell
down on everything that we owned and my
eldest son's nursery included
um
we're a little bit confused as to why
we're finding ourselves in a situation
where we are having to keep appealing
and trying to get applications through
because there are so many down our road
with similar if not identical features
in terms of length width and the finish
on them there's one down the end that's
changed shape so that it's not none
other down the road and has cedar
cladding and there's even one four doors
down that has just been granted
permission for two dormers longer than
my dormer and and it's despite the six
objections that it's received from
neighbours is still being granted
permission with cladding we've never had
any objections to ours we've only ever
had letters of support and we're
currently in the same situation we have
76 letters of support six of which are
from our neighbours and we're just i
know it isn't the case but we can't help
but feel a little victimized and a
little that would be a made an example
of
um
we are at breaking point with this
financially emotionally mentally um
and we just the thought of having to
tear our home down is heartbreaking um
we have managed to secure some finances
from families so that we can
put some hanging toes excuse me um to
try to help with the appearance of this
um we just cannot financially
we haven't we can't afford to to do this
my father-in-law's health is failing and
he wants to move in and we can't even
offer that as an option because there's
a potential that our home could be
talking down around us
so we are hoping that you just find some
compassion please help end this
nightmare for us so that we can actually
enjoy our home
and if you're still of a view to um
if you still have a view to turn this
down i please recommend that you visit
and and i'm happy to have you do a site
visit or whatever you need to do
but and thank you for listening
sorry
uh please don't uh apologize this
committee and myself and officers
understand
your feelings
i will ask ever now please to give her
report
thank you chairman
but i asked you to push the little
button to turn your microphone off
please okay
thank you
sorry um so this is the application site
outlined um in red here
um so it's um
mainly a retrospective application so
this application has been in um a number
of times before so the main difference
between previous applications and this
application is the changing materials so
the photo you see before you is the the
proposal which is the dormer to the
front elevation and a dormer to both
side elevations
as as you can see the photo's currently
showing that the dormers have um
grey bluey um cladding um to the cheeks
of the dormers so this proposal is to
remove that and to toll hang all of the
dormers to match the existing roof tiles
so this is a view
of the side door so this dorm you can
see here is of the greatest concern um
due to the size of it and the proximity
to the eaves level
and then this is it further down the
road and you can see again surrounding
bungalow so there are quite a few um
similar
in terms of dormer extensions down the
road um but this is considered to be
particularly large in terms of proximity
to the eave level
um this again you can just see the
dormer in the distance there and then
this is from the other side so the other
side is a slightly smaller dormer set
behind the main roof
and again you can see it's still
currently clad but again that is also
proposed to be tolhang
so these were the existing elevations um
prior to any work taking place on the
property
um in 2017 the original application was
submitted the plans were amended in
order to reduce the scale of the dormers
and this was the plan that was approved
so you can see on the right hand side of
this plan the door mark is is much
reduced in scale set down from the ridge
line and set up quite considerably from
the ease level
um the dormers were similar size and
were quite balanced on the property
and then this is the proposed so
whilst work have taken place and the
the dormer has been enlarged i
understand this may be linked to the
internal staircase configuration but has
resulted in a much larger dominant
dormer
in terms of the size of it it's
1.4 metres deeper than the previously
approved doorman making it 3.7 metres
deep and it's also 1.7 meters wider than
the original dormer resulting in a width
of 7.5 meters
so
this is the other side so the one that's
got the smaller dormers on it so this
was a previously approved plan again
from 2017
and then this is what's been built so we
have less concerns with this side given
the fact that the um dormer is still set
up from the eu's level and the dorms are
much smaller in size and there's a break
between the dormers so there's less
concern with this side of the property
um and then this was the um the again
this the other side which has the
greatest concern so this was what was
approved so you can see the the width of
the prop of the dormer and how much it's
set up from the ease level
and then this is now what's been built
so it's um wider again dropped down to
the ease level there's an extra window
in that side elevation as well
and then this is the view from the rear
elevation
so in terms of the history of this the
the application was originally submitted
in 2017 as as mentioned the
dorms were amended and reduced in scale
and then that application was approved
um the dormers were then built larger
than the approved plans and
um an application was then submitted for
these dormers and this has been refused
so this was um
refused due to the scout and the
materials of the dormers an enforcement
notice was then served um which was
appealed but the inspector agreed with
us and this was upheld
then a further application um was
submitted to us with very slight
amendments um reducing the roof lights
in the
in the roof slope and slightly changing
the window design this was refused by
planning committee in 2020 due to the
scale and form of that larger dormer and
the colour and finish of the weather
building
this decision has then been appealed
again and through that appeal
amen mendy plans were put forward with
the tile hanging so the inspector
considered
that this these dormers of this scale
and the toll hanging through the appeal
process
and the appeal was dismissed so
the inspector's view on the dormer was
that the northeastern dormer is a large
addition to the roof of the dwelling and
unlike the southwestern dormers which
are partially hidden from view can
clearly be seen from the road
it's not subservient in comparison to
the size and simple picture of the main
roof and by virtue of its position and
size the dormer is a visual dominant
addition to the roof
and then in terms of the tile hanging
that was proposed to replace the
cladding the inspector said that the use
of tile hanging or an alternative colour
for the cladding has been suggested and
whilst this may go some way to
addressing the harm he's found it would
not address the scale and size of the
north north eastern dormer specifically
and therefore his conclusions on the
main issue do not change on the basis
that the inspector has given a view on
these dormers of this scale and of
dormers with the tile hanging and
considered it to be unacceptable we have
no option but to to recommend the
refusal of this application
on the
scale of the dormer within the northeast
elevation thank you
uh thank you emma i move the opposite
recommendation is adopted with the vice
chair please second
or second nature thank you council
common cook members
does anybody wish to comment
cal stagna
thank you
um i
i understand this is very difficult
application
um
there's i've seen quite a lot of history
with it i can understand where
um
the officers are coming from
um but i do have a few concerns and a
couple of questions that i'd like to ask
about it
um we've heard mention and i've read in
a number of the
a number of the letters that have been
submitted in support
that this isn't a one-off
on this estate there are a number of
other
um
similar
dormers
and as was mentioned one i think four
doors down at number 101
which is
larger than this one and in fact if i
remember rightly reading one of them
that um
and i'll just read
so as i'll get this right
that planning permission was granted for
the dorm at number 101 and the delegated
report
actually made reference to the this
development
in justification for that scheme
so well i can understand everything that
that's been said i really think this is
rather unfair
that um this this one seems to be
focused on and needing to be um
needing to be
rejected
as when there are a number of others on
the estate that have been approved
and i'd also just like to ask
about the enforcement action and what
actually
that enforcement action would mean to
this
property if that was enacted
i think account you
emma can you come back on that regarding
what enforcement
would actually mean
um in terms of other properties on in
the road yes we've had a lot of
applications over
over the years for extensions to um the
properties and we've had lots of dorm
applications submitted i think the one
that you're referring to specifically
and 101 boston road from what i
understand from the officer that dealt
with this application
that whilst that dormer was wider it
wasn't as low to the east level as this
one so i think the biggest concern with
this is how much how deep it is
projecting out from the side of the roof
and how close to the east level is so i
don't think that's an actual um
comparable um application because the
dorm is different in size
um but yes i appreciate there are lots
of other dormer extensions around
here in this road but i'm not sure if
there's anything actually comparable to
this size
and then in terms of the enforcement
notice i think is just going to cover
this point
um thank you yes um so a notice um as
was previously served would look to
effectively state that the
um for the application
um for the for that i suppose the
development sorry to be effectively
changed to match what was approved
because obviously we have got an
approval on this on this scheme
um previously um which would effectively
form the notes from the process of
serving a notice obviously there would
still be another opportunity to appeal
that notice
um if that notice wasn't was then upheld
and then wasn't complied with then it is
something that's then reported um you
know to the court if it's not complied
with obviously um that would that would
depend on a number of factors but
there's both an opportunity to appeal
this application but also an opportunity
to appeal the enforcement notice as well
as has been done previously
thank you
okay so thank you i understand that i
think one thing
one thing i'm considering here and i
think we we maybe could all consider
is whether the um
with the scale of this dormer you know
is is so
totally inappropriate
that um that it deserves
you know it's disproportionate to the
scale of the infringement that that
enforcement i think we could consider
that actually although this may be
slightly larger than it should be it's
similar to others on the estate
um and some as you said might be wider
than this and i think
to
to um
to reject this proposal would be totally
disproportionate to the action that
would follow and the impact it would
have on the um on the family who live in
this property
so i think that we have to
as well as following guidelines we have
to have a little bit of um compassion
when we make these decisions
uh
thank you councillor ghana but i i think
i'm not half person i think you know
that
i do understand what you're getting at
but we are dealing with what again is in
front of us this evening
um
sorry
just so yeah and
all of that is in front of us this
evening when making this decision
right it remembers i thank you for that
council connor you're another member
sorry
okay let's get your name right this time
council hopkinson
thank you
um
i mean i take the point about um
the the the um the fact that this
this uh dawn has been referred to in
another um
uh planning application that was granted
but it's different but i do feel a
little uncomfortable
in refusing permission on the basis that
this has been referred to with another
application um
um
mr livingstone about the um
you probably did say this earlier just a
check so you you the the idea would be
if this is refused then to for it to be
amended to fit in with what has been
approved um was that approval granted
retrospectively
um after the the development what was it
granted before
um thank you it was it was i believe it
was granted before development occurred
and i think um
the speaker outlined that obviously
there was approval was granted and it
was then changed um during construction
i believe
um
so um so yes it would be um you know it
would be to
effectively that's what the previous
enforcement notices i believe sought to
do
as a change to to accord with what was
permitted
thank you uh
councillor grinden
just about um i confess i'm i'm torn but
i do have one question i i know it's
been said but can you recap on what is
um
recommended with the cladding
that is the rather gray
cladding that is there at the moment
that's rather different to the rest of
the property
um so we propose to remove the cladding
completely on all three dormers
and to replace it with towel hanging
so the tower hanger will basically be
tiles to matching the roof of the
existing property so it'd be the same
color tiles as you can see on the
existing roof and that will be just hung
around
all of the dormers
uh i think council right
no
how's the shock
well we do listen to our plan officers
uh obviously they're the experts but
when you look at dormer
the only thing that really sticks out is
the color
i think we've all got hearts we do
listen
believe it or not
and i think if that was cloud if that
that cabin was taken off and had kent
peck tiles were the same it wouldn't it
wouldn't show as much that's my thoughts
on that i mean it's very difficult i do
take on board what the officers have
said and
approved before but this is quite large
than that but
if you don't do it this one there'd be a
whole rodan
doing the same they probably are anyway
so if that was just taken off and had
kent pegs all the same tiles it wouldn't
show up so much thank you
thank you eric how so keen
thank you can you just tell me are they
the other or some of the other bungalows
in the area with um the dormer
extensions have they also got cladding
or are they tired
and i think i think there probably are
some i don't have any examples but there
probably are some that have them
could i ask you please just a moment
please
yeah just to confirm there are there are
examples of of of cladding in in the
area
uh thank you i have other speakers uh
councillor bayford
thank you chair i mean i am familiar
with botany road and i have to say there
are many extensions and this one doesn't
particularly out of place any more than
any other to me but i i understand that
tonight we're considering this
application alone um i think i agree
with the comments that councillor shonk
has made it it is the colour that stands
out
um
how
difficult would it be to change that to
make it
more in keeping with the with the uh
the rest of the street and
would that
satisfy
um
the requirements or would the bulk and
scale still be an issue
thank you to cancer baby i'll come to
council right
i'm going to be the bad guy here i think
i mean i'm looking at this and i'm
thinking if i lived next door i would
feel that i was
crammed in i think it's overbear i think
it's too big it's overbearing
and i'm not sure that to change the
materials would make any difference
sorry
i think accounts are right um
any other member wish to
counsel ghana
yeah just so just clarify this
application actually does propose
um
replacing the cladding
on here to make it fit in
yeah so that is what
yeah so that's
i think
that can makes us happier yeah that
canopy
can be
canceled
thank you chair
it's
it's not just the cladding
we're going on about the cladding and
the tiles that's been sort of accepted
it's the size of it
the original planning application was
not that size
that has been totally disregarded and
they've built something a lot bigger
sure it would be better with tiles and
that's agreed but
but it's not the tiles it's the size of
it
thank you jim
thank you council com cook and
that is correct we are looking at the
size and obviously if which i'm sure you
have your paperwork and so forth as it's
been explained about the appeal
and so on so um
any other members and i know it's a very
different one for everyone counselor pat
moore
thank you chair
uh looking at it it might be a little
large
it might be not what it should be but
i'm sure that they would have learned
their lesson by now
and i think we should show a little
compassion
and approve it
uh thank you for that uh council more
yeah yeah now
uh righto members i think we've had a
quite a discussion debate on that i am
going to put this to the vote which
as you know is the officer's
recommendation is refer refusal
um you know the grounds for that so
those in favor of the refusal please
show the hands
those against
abstentions
right that has failed
come to mrsa
um so members of of outlined um in the
debate um and the mems some members
consider that the changing materials is
considered sufficient
um to mean that the development in terms
of its current scale would be in keeping
with the character appearance of the
area um and therefore if a member was to
propose to approve the application as
submitted they just need to state those
reasons to give reasons for approval um
to be to be recorded
all right
you wish to comment
help you propose yes
i don't wish to comment i wish to
propose that's fine along the lines as
outlined by mr livingstone that this
application be approved
thank you a second let me have a second
uh
councillor clinton
okay confirm yes um
and we'll come back on that
i will put it to the vote
um just to clarify um if if councillor
ghana was so minded and the second who i
think james has recorded was also mind
um it will be requested that there was a
condition that the materials were to
match the tiles of the existing roof
slope but that's entirely for the
council to decide
yeah so i am so minded
thank you for that council ghana thank
you that councillor
crindon that's been seconded members
those in favor of what you've heard
there
please your hands
yes
counselor i'll come to you because
you pre-proposed it and get the words
right
i'm proposing
what mr livingston said that we're
approving this
on the condition that um
the tiles that replace the cladding are
the same as the roof
thank you council aquino will come to
you i know we've had a vote thank you i
mean just just a point here um i would
like to propose that we just approve it
as is so where does that go
with voting
um so obviously the motion has been put
forward first i think just a point of
clarification before that motion is
voted on the application is
proposing to change the tiles
um so that is that is what is being
considered so the consideration of
leaving it as it is is not under
consideration this evening
council pet more
sorry
sorry
if
the color
is all wrong
why do they have to go to the expense of
putting tiles on why can't they just
paint it brown
i think
counts uh
more i mean that's not for us to decide
this evening i can't understand the game
where you're coming from but we can't
but i thought
we've decided
we have
we have but um we can't say what color
and so forth they can't do that here
it'd be better painted whatever i i know
your feelings
i say we are human so okay
fine
thank you uh
i think we finished on that one i like
yes we'll have a vote on what's been
proposed
please
mr lewis will do it so the motion is to
approve the application
um
as the change in materials is considered
sufficient to mean the development will
be in keeping with the character and
appearance of the area subject to a
condition requiring the roof tiles sorry
the tiles to match the existing roof
tiles
understand
okay
i think i think that is fair so
please show hands if you agree
those against
absentians
that has been
carried
and
[Applause]
thank you
i take it that some members of the
public will be leaving us um
that
i'll just give a few give a few moments
for you to
depart
thank you ladies and gentlemen
we get back to our business tonight
with the agenda which is agenda item
5 f
ws coal and sun 116 mountain street
moncton ramsgate and on this point i
have to ask
councillor shank to
leave the meeting
councillor
as you make other counselors strongholia
indicated he had an interest in
those of the coal family and so on
thank you
uh speaking in favor of the application
is a mr payne do we have mr payne
sorry we've kept you waiting a little
while tonight mr payne but you have
three minutes
good evening
my name is stuart payne i'm from harper
architects with the architects of the
cold yard proposal
we're proposing to create a new mixed
housing and retirement flats development
on existing brownfield sites the rear of
116 mountain street and the site has
been identified in the local plan as
being a residential development site and
our clients wanted to use this
designation to help residents to stay in
the area rather than being priced out by
larger more commercially minded housing
developments
our clients the coals have lived in the
village for several generations and are
valued members of the community
and the principle of development is to
allow for a mixed variety of housing
types and sizes designed for people of
all ages from starter homes to family
homes
through to retirement flats
this will help to create an inclusive
community feel and cater for local
residents who still want to stay in the
area when retiring or younger families
wanting to buy their first home
we've undertaken extensive research in
the area and hosted the community
consultation meetings
to discuss the various options
and to find out what the local residents
want on the land
we collected questionnaires and spoke to
local residents and those in the local
area at length about their concerns
with the increased number of
developments in the village
the aim was to create a well-rounded
proposal for the local community that
they could be proud of
their proposal also allows for a village
shop to further serve the community
the land has been designed to have
affordable housing
starter homes towards the front of the
site family homes and disabled
accessible dwellings in the center
and purpose built residential retirement
flats at the south end of the site
the development is landscaped to allow
for trees native bushes and wildflower
plant beds to help soften the landscape
and the retirement flats surround an
enclosed garden with ponds and planting
we have made every effort to keep as
many trees as possible and have included
for additional planting to help screen
the site and mitigate local residents
concerns
there have been some comments from
residents of cmark close which we have
made a priority to address we feel that
lowering the height of the retirement
flats um reducing
uh sorry redesigning the first floor to
alleviate overlooking concerns and
reducing the houses which back onto this
road to a
story and a half height
we hope they've helped to mitigate these
worries
all outstanding concerns regarding
ecology agricultural drainage
archaeology transport etc have been
resolved and the proposal has the
support of the
uh with the council the parish council
local councillors and many of the public
um so we therefore request planning
mission be granted
thank you
thank you mr payne raising points of
concern is mr smith
if you're there
we have three minutes thank you mr smith
thank you um committee um mr payne just
mentioned that there was support for the
scheme among local people these um this
reference is a result of a consultation
that took place in 2019
with purely aspirational ideas of what
was actually going to be proposed for
the site
now that we've seen some of the detail
that support has it has gone away
we've done two paper-based surveys and
one online community survey
of those people that expressed the
preference 90 of the local people are
against this development
we have 76 against with seven in support
one of those seven in support actually
admitted they clicked wrong button on
the facebook page
the houses on the west of the site will
back directly onto the existing homes in
seymour close and will be 7.8 meters
high the gardens of the proposed new
homes appear to be quite small
around 10 meters
on to
number five c-mark close to just six
meters on number 12.
the existing homes on the eastern side
of seymour close that will be overlooked
on
predominantly bungalows at four point
meters from the back garden fence of
number 15 seymour close this again is a
bungalow and will be dwarfed by a
two-story block of flats
the council's planning application the
local plan sets out that the plans will
be
set out that policies and proposals will
be used to guide decisions on
investments and development in
regeneration up to 2031.
yet the council officers appear to be
telling you already that your local plan
that is less this just about a year old
is already out of date and we should
override it
the plan states very clearly
two places for development in moncton
one is walters hill farm which is
already underway for 20 properties as
set out in the local plan
and the other is this cold yard
development again the local plan says 20
properties not 37 that is currently
proposed we urge the committee to do
what it says in a local plan use that to
guide your decision making and we
conclude by saying the development is
not wanted by local people despite
what's been said
it is too tall it is too close and too
dense and it is against the council's
current local plan thank you for
listening
uh thank you mr smith uh also raising
points of concern is miss smith yes no
relationship right thank you no
relationships
yeah
um right local residents asked council
officers and councillors on the planning
committee to visit the coals yard site
in november 2020 when the sheer scale of
this proposed development and the impact
it would have on existing homes and the
village as a whole became clear
we were told at the time that no such
visits were taking place due to the
kobit pandemic we understand that
sitefit is visits can now take place
again
we believed and still do that in if the
impact the development will have on the
existing properties in c-mark glows was
to be seen by those determining this
application they would have a far better
understanding of the reasons for the
strong objections among local people
various new developments are already
underway in the village and if this
application for another 37 homes were to
be approved the village will grow by
almost a third in just four years
another application is to be considered
by the planning committee this evening
that actually shares a boundary with the
coal yard development it's known as the
hay hill site and is next on your agenda
the hay hill development is seeking
permission for another 49 homes if this
too gets approved a total of 86 new
homes will be imposed on the village
that is made up of around 250 homes in a
single night
this is a number that is utterly
unreasonable and incredibly unfair
the plans for the colgard development as
drawn to date simply do not show
sufficient detail in terms of the impact
that the new buildings would have on the
existing homes particularly those in
cmark close
we note that building appearance and
final heights are to be reserved matters
but fear that once the outline
application is approved local people
will no longer have a chance to object
to these details
we still believe the planning committee
and planning officers would benefit from
a site visit to ensure they have a full
grasp of the proposals before coming to
a decision
we urge the committee to reserve
judgment on both the cole's yard and hay
hill applications until a site visit can
be arranged both applications have been
in existence for more than a year so
surely delaying the decision by a few
more weeks to allow a site visit to take
place is not unreasonable
council officers and planning committee
members should visit the village to see
for themselves the impact of both
applications at least having done so you
will have the knowledge and
understanding of the various issues with
these developments that will allow you
to make an informed opinion
86 new homes in the village of just 250
is a massive change surely such huge
change deserves to be assessed on the
ground so to speak before decision is
reached thank you for listening
uh thank you very much
speaking on behalf of the mutton parish
council is parish councillor brown
good evening members i'm speaking
something of a croaky voice tonight as
chairman of moncton parish council
and we're in favor of officers
recommendation to approve this
application
the application did indeed earn wide
support with villages at the initial
consultation stage
we were pleased to see the plans were
addressing a recognized housing lead in
the village with the proposal to build
retirement homes for older residents and
starter homes for younger families
and young people
by contrast almost all recent
development in mountain has been in the
form of four to five bedroom executive
properties which clearly does not meet
village need
the parish council wish to acknowledge
the fact that concerns have been raised
about this development and indeed they
have been raised this evening
in particular i want to mention those
raised by the residents of sea mark
close who joined the development site
and many other villages concerned about
the impact of further development in the
village
the parish council has tried extremely
hard to balance these concerns with the
fact that the site is allocated for
development plus the fact the architects
have gone to some considerable length to
mitigate the impact on sea marketplace
developments by reduced height buildings
and generous separation from their
properties
this consideration as a parish council
has been pleasing and refreshing to see
as it is the fact that there are as is
the fact there are no highways
alterations also associated with this
application
on a separate note as a village we have
barely any facilities or services the
proposal therefore to reintroduce a
village shop as part of the development
is viewed extremely positively
in summary this is a brownfield site and
it is identified for development in the
local plan
the proposed plans meet guidelines
and address a genuine housing need in
the village
taking all of the above into account on
balance the parish council view this as
a good development for the village and
therefore support the recommendation to
approve it thank you
thank you very much councillor brown
i'll ask now the planning officers to
outline the report here
thank you
the application is for the erection of
19 dwellings and 18 retirement flats so
the application is uh it also includes a
enlargement of an existing single-story
building to form a retail unit
so it is an outline application but a
lot of the matters are before members
this evening the only matters that are
being reserved until a later date and
submission is the actual detailed
appearance of the properties but there
are some indicative plans showing the
appearance which members will see
so this is the local plan map which
shows the allocation of the site as
already outlined
the site was given
an indicative 20 units as part of the
work through the local plan to indicate
the numbers proposed
so it is an allocated housing site the
site is a series of storage and workshop
buildings
accessed from mountain street
so looking at an aerial view of the
village you can see sea mark close
which is here stretching from the top to
the bottom of the image which is to the
west of the exist the application site
you can see as well just down the bottom
here
the edge of moncton's recreation ground
and the pavilion
which is where the mouse pointer is at
the bottom of the screen
and you can see the track that runs all
the way through the application site
just looking at it in a little bit more
detail
you can see there's a collection of
buildings around the existing vehicular
access and then a series of of workshop
buildings behind
and we just go through through some
images going through the site and then
looking back towards those buildings
so this is that access to the site so on
the left hand side you have a dwelling
which isn't part of this application
which we'll see in detail in the next
image you can see an existing two-story
workshop building behind the van here
which is proposed to be demolished as
part of the scheme
you then have this this garden area
which is going to form part of a parking
area next to the village hall which is
on the right hand side of the image
so this is the property that's outside
the application site
and not not proposed for anything to
happen to on the left of the access
then behind the cars there is this the
garden area and you can see the uh the
village hall on the right hand side
there is also this property here which
is a two-story property with a pitched
roof
which is also
outside of the application site so
there's nothing proposed to happen to
that property
and so this is just a view down further
down monkton street where you can see
the front of the village hall
so this is opposite the site which is
the uh the school
uh and then this is moving inside the
site so this on the left-hand side you
can see the two-story building to be
demolished
so you can see the access runs through
um a sort of narrow point where there is
uh landscaping on one side uh and on
others there is some landscaping that's
being lost as part of this development
to accommodate the road and link in to
the site
um turning to the right of the image
that we're looking at there
shows the the side elevation of that
two-story property that's not part of
the application site
this area in front of this
this property
would is part of the application site
and would form part of the road which
we'll look at when we're looking at the
proposed layout
on the left hand side you've got a
single story building which is to be
demolished
behind the fence is the location of the
storage building which is to be enlarged
for a single story flat roofed retail
unit
so then this is a view looking back
towards the primary school which is
opposite so you can see the the building
on the right now which is the two-story
building
to be demolished
and then turning back around and going
further into the site you can see that
some of the landscaping that's going to
be removed on the right hand side here
and you can see a sort of high single
story workshop building
on the left-hand side of the image which
is to be demolished and then going
further into the site around the corner
this is the corner on the left-hand side
of that
building you see you've got a number of
structures here on the site all of which
to be cleared
and then this is looking back towards
the extent of the built mass at the
moment back to that two-story warehouse
building
this is even further back into the site
which obviously as you can see forms um
a builder's yard and open storage
um then this is back further into the
site so you can see that there is
landscaping both within the site and
also on the boundaries of the site
either side um you can see in the uh in
the center of the image a tree which is
actually outside the application site
which we'll i'll point out on the site
plan as well which is one of the more
dominant trees in the middle of the site
or adjacent to the middle of the site
and then this is a view looking back
towards the the back of the site there
is a lot of a lot of land that's
overgrown towards the back of the site
um but we'll look at the plans showing
that the proposed landscape and so you
can see what's happening with the
different trees
so i'm going to show some views from
seamark close now so to show the the
character of that road and the existing
relationship looking over towards the
site
um so this is um looking at properties
as you start to go down seem up close so
you have
a mixture of types of bungalows so
you've got the um
i won't use the term chalet bungalow
again um you've got a bungalow with
front door windows in
the the that are semi-detached but then
as you go further down the road you get
into pitched roof bungalows without
those roof additions and then a change
in design as you get to the end of that
cul-de-sac um with the um with the
bongos that you can see here so in the
background here you can see some trees
um which are at the back of the
application site and again we'll point
these out on the site plans when looking
at them
so this is the form of the proposal
um and because of the the nature of the
the plan split this down into two so
we'll start by looking at the front of
the site
um so
as mentioned at the front of the site in
that garden area you have
seven parking spaces to be created um
for
visitors to either the village hall or
indeed to the shop for use so they're
for general use with a new um and
retarmac vehicle access through the site
immediately where the location of the
two-story workshop building was that we
looked at in the photos um is proposed
to have a row of two-story terraced
properties
uh
sorry four of four of those terrace
properties opposite the single-story
shop
then as you move through the site
we have a variety of of scale of
properties which we'll look at in the
next plan
but you can see that what's being
proposed is a very linear street pattern
with semi-detached properties as you go
through and then some detached
properties
to the eastern extent of the road at the
bottom of the image here
and then down at the bottom you have the
retirement units
development of 18 units with a turning
head as well with 28 parking spaces to
serve
those flats
you can also see the pavilion that we
mentioned
earlier
with
some exis those existing trees which are
the ones with the
with the black lines within them um
which are the existing ones to be
retained uh we'll talk a bit more about
the landscaping but the the trees that
you can see that don't have those
indented black lines are proposed trees
rather than those trees to be retained
so looking at the scale of development
because that is something that members
are considering this evening this has
been amended through the course of the
application
and so what you have if we look at the
right uh hand side image you have
detached two-story properties as type b
those four terrace properties where the
existing two-story workshop is but set
slightly back
you have a single-story flat roof retail
unit
you then move into what's denoted here
is type e which is in green
and these are um they are single story
buildings with rooms in the roof with
front and rear door windows so they
could be classed as two-story dwellings
but they certainly have first floor
accommodation so that's something we'll
look at in terms of the relationship
with the neighboring properties so they
have changed from two story properties
uh originally submitted so you've got a
collection of those which the ones in
green then type d which is the ones in
red
are the full two-story properties
they're the detached units
and then the
retirement flats to the south of the
site um so this is a two-story building
so it's got a bigger pitch but again it
has door more windows or um
larger door windows in that roof space
so it's a it's two-story but with rooms
in the roof but with larger doors that
we'll see
so looking at some long sections again
these are indicative plans the detailed
appearance would be subject to a
separate application but this gives you
an idea of the scale of the building so
if we take the middle sorry if we take
the top image
on the left hand side you can see that
building to be retained that was right
on the junction and access to the site
um so you can see that the design of the
that that block of four terrace
properties are matching the eaves height
and the ridge height of those uh that
existing building
at the front of the site
and then in the middle image you can see
um the
uh the scale and indicative design of
the
single story building with dorm windows
front and back
which we'll look at in a bit more detail
and then there are the detached
buildings which obviously on the eastern
side of that access
so that's the on the right hand side of
that middle section and then at the
bottom you have the
elevation showing the scale of the
retirement units so again you can see
there that you've got first floor
accommodation not quite dormal windows
but they're you know more significant in
scale
and then actually on the bottom image
you can see on the right hand side there
the pavilion so you can see there's a
changing level to where they've got the
pavilion which is obviously to the south
of the site
so this is just a bit of a detailed view
of the
proposed
units which really form the majority of
the houses in the development
um so the the detailed materials and
design of this would be fixed at um
reserve matter stage however these are
indicative plans so if this was to be
submitted um you know that it well could
be this is submitted because obviously
we are still looking at the scale and
the scale is defined by the height to
the eaves and the height in the roof
space and indeed that ridge height so
that is what members are considering
this evening
so in terms of that relationship with
properties on c-mark close
as mentioned all of the properties on
the western side are that
that
single-story with dorm windows front and
back in the roof
you can see that
there is a distance between the
bungalows
in cmark close and that relationship is
one that obviously officers did consider
was quite important to reduce the scale
of the buildings that were proposed so
there are still going to be first floor
windows proposed facing towards seymour
close the distance has been considered
to be sufficient back to back so we're
looking at 31 meters back to back we do
think because of the scale of those
units
and the fact that they are pitching away
with dorm windows we don't consider
giving that distance that there would be
a sense of enclosure or indeed loss of
light to those properties given that
that minimum 31 meters distance
in terms of the retirement flats to the
south uh there is a tightening of the
properties on c-mark close to this site
as you can see it's got closer and
therefore this has been looked at in
terms of whether or not amendments were
necessary and in this instance they were
on the basis that the windows would have
resulted in our view of of overlooking
to the rear of that adjacent property on
on c mark close and therefore both the
condition and indeed the plans have been
submitted
to confirm that the first floor windows
on the western flank of that building
would be obscure glazed up to 1.7 meters
in height above finished floor level
and that is
echoed and showed by the floor plans
which indicate that there's only one
unit which uh two units which well sorry
it's one unit but with two different
rooms which would have that um that 1.7
meter obscure glazing the rest of the
windows in that flank are serving
hallways so that they're not going to
result in overlooking either
um so just to again confirm that sort of
roof design
of and the scale of that building
for the retirement flats and then just
confirm here's a confirmation of the
section showing the 1.7 meters that
would be required in terms of the
obscurity of those of those windows
so to talk about transportation there
are
80 spaces in total proposed in this
application to serve the development um
so every dwelling has two off-street
spaces that will be provided and as
mentioned earlier the retirement flats
have have 28 um
28 parking spaces there's also park uh
parking for the ambulance directly in
front of an ambulance directly in front
of the retirement flats and there's also
turning facilities that have been
provided for any delivery vehicles
serving the retail unit as well as some
visitor parking spaces and some parking
spaces opposite the retail unit
for that as well as those mentioned
spaces at the front of the site
of which there are there are seven which
are for for general use
in terms of the access to the site um so
this is a you know a key issue um
obviously it is an existing access and
it does serve obviously builders yard
vehicles
but what has been looked at here as you
can see in the bottom left of the image
is tracking showing um ambulances um
longer vehicles
to be able to access and turn in and out
of the site one thing that does mean is
that the bus stop is being relocated
to five meters to the west
um of of the existing location to ensure
that there isn't any conflict between if
a bus was parked and any vehicles
turning out to the
uh to the west on the left-hand side of
the image
kcc have have looked at this access and
do consider that it is
sufficient in a on a safety purpose for
safety purposes
in terms of landscaping
so this has been looked at in uh with a
bit of back and forth and quite a bit of
detail
um so as mentioned the trees um that
have the uh i suppose black lines within
them within those those green circles
are the trees to be retained there are
trees within the site that are to be
lost as part of the proposal it is
considered that the allocation of the
site would have resulted in the loss of
trees here and the the vast majority of
trees that that result in the most both
screening um to residents of adjacent
properties and also immunity value of
within the development are being
retained on the either side boundary uh
it is proposed for trees to be planted
along the actual uh road as well which
obviously as members will know from the
training is a requirement of um of the
mppf changes um they're proposed to be
filled maple trees and we are putting a
condition on that would request some
additional landscaping details by virtue
of the fact that there's a native
hedgerow mix that's being proposed but
we've asked for sort of some additional
details of of that
but we are
comfortable with the the balance between
retaining the trees on the site
and those to be lost
if we go to the south of the site
um there has been um some additional
work that's been done through the
application and one of the reasons why
it's taken so long to get to members is
because kcc ecology when looking at the
preliminary ecological appraisal that
was done have requested additional
information and indeed requested
additional surveys for bats and reptiles
which were undertaken earlier this year
and what that has resulted in is some
specific mitigation that's required to
be accorded with which would involve the
translocation of any reptiles that are
found during the course of development
to the south of the site
so you can see a pink line which is
dotted uh which shows uh the receptor
site around the edge where there's going
to be a landscape buffer with
from the retirement flats to the
pavilion
you've also got the inclusion of back
boxes and back bricks and
bird bricks
to ensure for the new build houses
as well as
some roosting space in the roof space of
the flats
they have gone back to kcc as mitigation
and it is considered that sufficient to
ensure there's no loss of biodiversity
from this site
and given the increase in tree cover
that would be proposed through the
landscaping is considered to be of
benefit in terms of biodiversity and
ecology
through in terms of air quality
there is the proviso of one electric
vehicle charging space per house and
one in 10 for communal
communal spaces for the flats
surface water drainage has also been
looked at it's been assessed
specifically by kcc
there is a specific condition which has
been requested by them
for the detailed surface water drainage
to be looked at um predominantly in
relation to ensuring that the
infiltration rates that have been put
forward in the strategy are accorded
with which is a standard condition for a
development of this scale to ensure that
infiltration rates are sufficient so
there is not runoff outside of the site
to cause surface water flooding issues
in terms of planning obligations the
heads of terms are outlined in the
report it outlines 30 affordable housing
that includes the retirement flats as
that's six houses and five flats there
is also a number of other contributions
which have been assessed to be in
accordance with the regulation one two
two including education contributions
contribution towards the ccg and also
the sam's contribution that members will
be familiar with
in terms of
the impact on the area in relation to
the allocation of the site um so the
principle of development has been agreed
through the local plan for housing
the numbers that are provided as part of
the local plan are the ones that are
taken forward when calculating the
council's five-year housing land supply
that does not mean that applications
that are submitted which are for more or
indeed less shouldn't be considered and
therefore need to be considered by
members in terms of whether or not the
development would have an adverse impact
on the character appearance of the area
or the impact on the countryside or on
the impact in this instance of the
landscape character area
in our opinion by virtue of the scale of
buildings that's been provided and would
be limited by virtue of an outline
approval it is considered that this
development would not result in harm to
the landscape character area it is
considered to be spacious enough to
avoid any impact on the countryside and
when added into the the particular
contributions the 30 affordable housing
it is considered that as well as the
provision of a a shop within the
development which accords with a
specific policy e13 which relates to
retail developments that serve villages
it is considered that the application is
acceptable and therefore the application
is deferred and delegated would be so
the recommendation is to defer and
delegate the application for approval to
officers to secure the legal agreement
which would secure those planning
obligations and subject to the
conditions outlined thank you chair
uh thank you very much for that ian i
moved the officer's recommendation is
adopted because the vice chair police
second
or second nature thank you council
common core members
council bayford
thank you chair
yes i mean this has been allocated for
housing and local plan it's a brownfield
site
i consider it's a sensitive development
the scale's been amended
um
consideration's been given to
overlooking with obscure windows on one
side
the landscaping has been is is generous
um
it's a spacious development we have
affordable housing
and contributions to be made in my view
um
i i have no doubt about um
sorry um
about uh going along with the officer's
recommendation to support this
application thank you thank you
councillor bayford cascana
thank you yeah um
i've had a good i've had a good read of
this report before come along today so
i've got just got a couple of questions
that i'd like to ask
um
one about
southern waters
um comments in the report the mention
about designing off-site sewage network
reinforcements
that are required
before this was able would be able to go
ahead i believe is what it's suggesting
and they're talking about limiting time
scales
to 24 months from a firm commitment of
the development so
i sort of i'd like to fully understand
what that means really
before i go on and
make further comments thanks
thank you scotland
um so
southern water obviously have
raised the issues of as you said the
need for reinforcements and this is
something that does obviously come up
quite a lot with regards to major
developments of this sort of scale so
there is a condition which requires that
no development should take place until
foul water
drainage arrangements are submitted to
us and obviously agreed in writing as
part of any submissions of conditions
details for drainage to do with foul
water we would consult with southern
water now under the water and
infrastructure act some water are
required to agree a connection to the
drainage network but what they can
require before any agreement for any
drainage to connect is actually
reinforcement works the existing
capacity which effectively the developer
would have to pay
to agree with them before the
development could connect to the network
so in this instance by virtue of the
condition safeguarding the drainage
arrangements would be sorted out prior
to development actually taking place it
is considered wouldn't result in any
issue with regards to capacity
to existing residents without the
improvement works that some would
require occurring thank you
okay
yeah okay i understand that i mean uh i
guess it could be argued
um that southern more to
require quite a significant amount of
work to their existing network to make
it fit for purpose
before any further
um any any further development including
this is
is permitted because they don't seem to
be able to
cope with what we've currently got um
without discharging profuse amounts of
sewage into the sea on regular occasions
but i understand that's a little bit
separate to this well there are one or
two comments in different sections
that cause some concern around
flood
flood potential on the site
um
kcc flood water management
mentioned that they have concerns
and they're utilizing a strategy
or they're
proposing an implementation of a
strategy utilizing permeable pavements
that would lead to soak aways
um
to control
control or try to control potential
flooding
as far as they're concerned um kcc
highways
also um mention the provision for uh
of
measures to prevent discharge of surface
water onto the highway um i think it
sort of
it sort of paints a picture that that
you know there is obviously a potential
for for flooding on this site
um and i
i sort of
like to assume that that might be one of
the reasons why although this site is a
broadcast site and was chosen that the
local plan limited it to 20
20 units rather than the
now 37 that proposed and so i do have a
concern that maybe we're again
overcrowding a site
and um not implementing
or not having in in or not having
adequate measures to deal with potential
flooding on the site so i think that's
that's another maybe question that you
might be able to answer
i think accounts garner yeah
thank you sir um yes so in terms of
surface water drainage any application
that's over 10 units or basically a new
housing development we consult with um
kcc as the local lead flood authority
and they obviously look at sustainable
drainage systems and obviously in this
instance what's being what was put
forward in the strategy included
permeable paving for this site um every
application site of this sort of scale
would require a surface water drainage
strategy which will include looking at
measures so to basically make sure that
surface water flooding on hard surfaces
is ameliorated by virtue of slowing down
the rate of discharge in this instance
through permeable paving the kcc's
specific comment relates to
the need for
a detailed scheme to come in again prior
to development commencing on the site
to look at
ensuring that infiltration rates um and
basically needing a ground investigation
report to make sure the infiltration
rates would be acceptable um in terms of
the capacity of the site
um i cannot speak in detail to the
rationale behind the 20 units that's
given but fundamentally that is often on
a character and appearance basis but
will also take in consol t views uh with
regards to what's going on um that would
include people such as highways and
other elements of kcc uh but
fundamentally kcc as the locally front
authority have not objected to
development and are in agreement with a
condition requiring those submission of
details in and again it's a grampian
condition which means if it's not
satisfied then the development can't
take place so i think that's an
important point in terms of whether or
not the conditions sufficient to
mitigate the impact which in our view uh
with the wording it certainly is
considered to do so thank you chad
uh thank you
can i just come back with you got one
more query or comment to make yes you
don't mind yeah
um
my final comment i think was was
sort of relates to what was raised by
the um by a couple of the residents who
spoke
um
on for i know we have to deal with each
application in
as we see it separate
um but of course we all we know that
once we've dealt with this application
we've got another application
to consider
following this that is um
that is on the site next door
um so i've got a concern that
the local plan states that this site
which is the only site in
in
in the village that that is being
considered here for 20
units and so understand the move up to
37 but then we're going to be
considering in isolation separate to
this
that the site next door is going to have
another
a few more i think and let's mention
making a total of 86
units which is going to have quite a
significant
impact on the village i've got quite a
big change and also quite a big impact
on the
the land that does deal with that does
enable the area to cope with heavy
rainfall and potential flooding so i ca
i can understand the suggestion that it
might be a good idea
for if we were able to go and actually
have a look at the both of them
um and then come back and consider them
both after after assessing the impact
after going to see it and the impact on
the village
um i don't i don't really know what the
the answer is to about not being able to
consider them both at the same time
uh thank you
um so obviously the application that's
that's
in front of you now
um is all could be considered in light
of what has happened in this vote
because it's happened if one of those
come to it but obviously it's really
important for for members in terms of
what the consultees have said with
regards to impact on infrastructure
that it's actually the the predominant
principle of development such as this
have to look at whether or not the
development washes its own face
effectively through both drainage other
infrastructure highway movements new
accesses etc
and so that's why obviously each
situation is looked at in that way
because obviously if that's the case
then each development would be able to
be accorded sufficient capacity and
infrastructure purposes so this
application is all that's being
considered obviously now as you say
that's the goal just to clarify that
point thank you
uh thank you thank you
councillor
thank you um observation um really on uh
a lot has been said about the number of
properties in the local plan compared to
the number of dwelling units here
but if it wasn't for the fact that an
awful lot of those dwelling units are
lumped together into a retirement block
um the difference in the numbers between
the local plan and if it was just houses
and probably aren't quite so great so i
don't i'm not seeing that as a major
issue
and i i'm hoping for some reassurance
going forward that when the parking is
done that that is sympathetic for
drainage
you talked about permeable pavements but
so often we don't see that so i realized
that would be part of the delegate thing
but those are just two comments really
uh thank you screen and i think that has
been noted as thank you um any other
council right
thank you mr chairman i'm i'm torn with
this one um
part of me says yes part of me says no
but um having heard that originally in
2020 there was a site visit arranged
that had to be postponed
um
i think i'd be happier if we could
recommend that we have a site visit
thank you come back to you after we do
this again um just to confirm in terms
of a site is it being postponed um
obviously i don't know the details of
the issue obviously the site has been
visited by officers in terms of inside
the site to look at the impact on on the
residential properties adjacent as well
as obviously the impact on the actual
site itself and obviously we've talked a
bit about the trees
um as well as looking at the environment
around there so the site has been
visited just to confirm that
but not by members
um
that may be true council right
council paul moore
yes thank you chair um you'll be glad to
know that most of my points have been
covered by the members um i'd just like
to ask the new highway that's being
proposed is that going to be adopted by
kcc
and also what provision have we got for
hydrants in that location
thank you chair um
i don't believe that the proposal would
adopt that highway um i will just
come back to you if that's okay just to
check that because i believe that that
kcc could still potentially adopt that
highway but i don't believe that's been
put forward by the the developer in this
instance
come back please um so in that sense
then it would be a private road
with private hydrants
possibly
yeah that would that would be the case
uh council more and i think you know a
little bit about that sort of thing so
any other members wish to
comment
okay i'm going to put this
to the vote with yourselves
those in favor please show the hand
please
yes
those against
oh sorry sorry can we go through that
sorry
pat you had your arm in the air for both
which is it is it stuck
i know it's getting late
members if you don't mind if we could do
that again those for this application
please show
that took a while
those against
abstentions
and that has been carried thank you very
much members
i don't know when he wants to go and
find
councillor shonk i think it's raining
outside
sounds like it mr chairman i think the
next application applies as well
no
i don't know
no okay no it doesn't
yes
i'll just wait for councillors shank to
come back in
uh thank you magnus
members of the public um
thank you karen shank i don't know he
had to run around the park with the
weather as it is at the moment
right um agenda item 5g which is the
planned application
for approval for land rear of 92 and 102
moncton street moncton
uh speaking in favor of this application
is mr coward if mr coward is with us uh
good evening yes thank you and again
sorry for keeping you
quite some time this evening but you
have three minutes
uh good evening i'm the agent for the
application we welcome the detailed
officer's report and of course a
recommendation to approve
i want to focus on one point namely the
principle of this development on the
site with regard to the nppf
this will explain why exactly the same
scheme has been submitted relatively
soon after the december 2020 appeal
decision i know the number of the
representations have mentioned this
with the last appeal the tilted balance
did not apply
now it does as the most recent housing
delivery test results confirm that the
authority have only delivered 54
of the houses needed any figure below
the threshold of 75
which is classified as being
substantially below the figure that it
should be triggers the tilted balance
i'm sure you're all familiar with it now
but the tilted balance confirms the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development and the mppf is very clear
that planning permission should be
granted unless any adverse impacts of
doing so would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits so
that's the way it's quite called the
tilted balance in that you need to
demonstrate significant and demonstrable
harm
and this is the key policy matter at the
heart of this application
the benefits of 49 new homes set against
a housing shortfall to include 30
affordable homes where there is a need
the inspector in the last appeal
concluded that the scheme would deliver
notable benefits
so we now then need to consider what the
inspector concluded in respect of harm
he had no issue with the impact of the
scheme upon the character and appearance
of the area and he concluded no material
landscape impact as of course members
are aware the scheme is surrounded on
three and a half sides by existing built
form
there was no issue with the loss of best
and most versatile agricultural land and
this issue was not on its own sufficient
to withhold planning permission
as members are aware the site is boxed
in on all sides is isolated from the
rest of the agricultural holding it's
not been farmed since 2016
and there's real issue with the
proximity to residential properties
arising from say harvest dust and the
risk of pestic pesticide spray drift
the inspector did however of course
conclude that the scheme was contrary to
the development plan specifically those
policies which require development to be
within settlement limits whereas of
course whilst we're well related to the
settlement we're outside of it but this
matter is now addressed by the tilted
balance which did not apply with the
last appeal this is the fundamental
change from the last appeal and this key
policy issue was not in play previously
whereas it is now
the scheme has gone through the appeal
system and the only harm to sufficient
to justify refusal of planning
permission has now been addressed with
this very clear change in circumstances
this is why the scheme is back with you
this is where we are
and this of course is why you've got a
recommendation before you thank you very
much
thank you mr card raising points of
concern is mrs johnson
mrs johnson three minutes
um we obviously don't agree with the
reasons given we don't agree that the
tilted balance has anything to do with
this at all
for a very small village there have been
a large number of objections from
residents i'm not going to go through
them because it's the second time you've
seen them and they have not changed
in addition to these objections i've got
some questions
why are there policies in place such as
a site being not within the village
confines and therefore within the
countryside in order to protect the
countryside if these policies can be
overturned almost on a whim
why if a piece of agricultural land is
not within the local plan when the local
plan is now ratified should it even be
considered for building on
how can building on yet another piece of
agricultural land be helping towards the
aim of a greener county and helping to
counteract the climate emergency a name
which we understand the council has
signed up to and now also has the
support of the prime minister
how can continuing to build a car
dependent dependent housing help towards
the above aim moncton is most definitely
a car dependent community
on what premises built the idea that
adding pressure to already overstretched
facilities can help to sustain them
moncton is not a sustainable village
if the officer's report needs to justify
the conclusion which appears to show why
the development should not take place
then surely the conclusion is right and
not the justification
although the unwanted and fiercely
opposed road scheme which hasn't been
mentioned which would need to be imposed
on our village in order for this
development to take place has been
agreed by kent highways something we are
a total loss to understand
how can it be right that this road
scheme will result in the waiting area
for traffic being nearer to our village
school
the impact of air pollution from traffic
fumes on young children is increasingly
being understood and this would be a
completely against current thinking if
it went ahead
with regard to this application we find
it hard to accept
that objections to planning applications
are taken into account
whilst we do agree that there are
housing issues in thanet building 49
mostly executive type houses in a field
in moncton is extremely unlikely to help
the real issues of homelessness for
thanet residents however quickly or
otherwise they are built and whatever
agreements have now been made
we feel the original decision was
totally right and this was confirmed by
the upholding of it by the inspector who
did note that the tilted balance existed
but ignored it and in one of his
conclusions noted and i quote it has not
been demonstrated that the development
is essential for the economic or social
well-being of the area and thus the
proposal conflicts with lp policy sp 26
and this is not the only policy it
conflicts with
we do not agree that there is anything
either in this resubmission or in the
offices report which challenges the
original decision in any way
or gives any grounds for changing it now
and we would therefore
urge you to help us
help protect our village and refuse this
application which continues to conflict
with the council's own policies
thank you mr johnson also raising points
of concern is mr annette
mr annette
put the record straight um
everybody keeps saying it's 96 to 102. i
actually live at 106. it affects me
greatly there's also 104 108 and a few
other houses that it actually affects so
it's not 96 to 102
and it's been that since it's actually
been actually been put the application
in
it affects a lot of static homes in fox
hunter park because they all overlook
this field
and it also affects 22 houses that are
opposite this by the time you get to the
school that isn't taking into account
the proposal double yellow lines that
are going to be put
put in
um tilted balance is a reason this is
been put and resubmitted again for the
same layout as it was before
policy spo one states primary focus for
new housing is that in is the district's
urban area and limited development of
the village of moncton as defined by the
local plan moncton is therefore clearly
within the countryside for the purpose
of planning policy and has already had
more than that limited development
local pal and policy sp 26 seeks to
conserve and enhance than its landscape
character and local distinctiveness
the proposed site is in the stale
marsh's landscape character area and the
policy says the development should be
directed away from the sound marshes as
this is one of the district's areas
which is largely undeveloped and key to
retaining the island character of planet
hay hill are suggesting that then
accounts district council cannot
demonstrate a 5 year surprise to local
housing sites with the appropriate
buffer and when the application was
refused it did not have a local plan
however this is not now the case as it
as it has an adopted plan now
what is the tilted balance the mppf
national policy planning framework 2019
states you must have a clear reason for
a refusal of planning commission as long
as you have a clear reason for refusal
which you have and have demonstrated
about refusing application previously
then you are correcting refusing
application again the plan inspector
also agreed with that council planning
commission rejected application on
appeals stating it was not within the
confines of the local plan or should be
developed due to the need of the
agriculture use of this land
in doing research in the child
development it is clear that this is an
approach that hey here are trained as a
desperate attempt to secure planning to
apply the tool to balance you must show
that there are no actual grounds for
refusal but the third digit council
planning committee and the planning
inspector have given proper reasons
these are outside the settlement
boundary of moncton village as defined
by the local plan it is therefore this
parcel of land is within the countryside
for the purpose of planning policy this
has not changed the planning is petra
actually commented on the so-called
tilting balance when he considered the
appeal and in his own words this land is
best the most versatile agricultural
land it is contrary to local plant
policies sbo1 and sp 24 which seek to
locate housing predominantly within
settlements and restrict developments in
the countryside
it has been clearly stated that this
site was until 2016 to have usable
farming land and detailed evidence has
not been provided that circumstances
have changed since 2016 to the extent
that there's no longer any realistic
proposal of the land being farmed
indeed interested party state farming
could resume immediately
it is worth noting that the new road
layout will have a major impact on the
residents of mountain street in a
statement made by hair hill the
inconsiderate parking residence of
mountain street and by removing the
on-street parking will make monkton
street safer actually inconsiderate
parking is people parking outside their
own homes thank you
thank you very much uh once again uh
speaking on behalf of the mountain
parish councillors parish councillor
brown
good evening again
as members are now aware this
application came before the committee in
2019
although it did not comply with planning
policy then it was nonetheless
recommended for approval mainly to meet
the district council short foreign
housing delivery
members we were pleased to see voted
against the application and this
decision as we are aware was later
ratified in the appeal process
and here we are again the same
application the same lack of compliance
the same reference to housing shortfall
and the same recommendation for approval
in their report offices clearly
highlight the fact that this proposal is
contrary to both the local plan
and planning policy on several counts
so why the recommendation to approve it
we have heard eloquence from the
applicant himself tonight but looking at
the actual report
the answer seems to lie in the drive for
housing delivery in thanet as is
dictated by the thanit by the local plan
so may i ask members to consider the
following
in the local plan moncton is required to
contribute 38 houses towards thanet's
housing delivery
now this may seem a small number but
we're a small village just 262 houses
prior to this evening 46 houses have
either already been built
are under construction or have been
granted planning approval so in actual
fact we have already met and exceeded
our local plan allocation
with cole's yard agreed this evening
this figure is now increased to 83 new
properties well over twice our
application
add to this the 49 house is being
considered here and as other speakers
have referenced this evening the result
will be a massive 50
increase in the number of houses in
mountain this is purely and simply
unsustainable
and it is hard not to draw the
conclusion that the recommendation to
approve this application
is much more about balancing the books
on housing delivery then it is a
balanced pragmatic application of
planning policy
should we be building at any cost
anywhere
just to balance the books of course we
shouldn't
147 letters of objection have been
submitted from villages the residents
association the local school
from the cpre other parish councils and
from residents and representative bodies
all the way across thanat
on behalf of all these people and
particularly the community i represent i
cannot urge members strongly enough to
refuse this application tonight you have
done so once
as has the inspectorate
please do so again thank you
thank you very much uh councillor brown
uh i've now asked the planning officer
which i believe is annabelle to give her
report
thank you chair
yeah this is an outline application as
has been mentioned for up to 49
dwellings which does include access for
consideration at this time but we've all
formatted to reserve for future
consideration the application site is
outlined in red
on the slide before you
and with muncton street running along
the top of the slide here
some members will indeed recognize
the site from the previous application
was that was considered
um at planning committee in january last
year
and that application was refused by
members on free grounds
the
loss of countryside and best and most
votes to our agricultural land and two
further technical reasons
relating to not securing affordable
housing
and other planning obligations and also
other not securing the sam contribution
that application was then dismissed
appeal in december of last year
excuse me and the appeal decision was
attached to the report in
the agenda for members to review
that this application is indeed a
resubmission of the previous application
and needs to be considered on its own
merits given
the fact that the council has now failed
its housing delivery test
so this is the application site here
in this area here
you have moncton street running across
the top fox hunters
to the east of the site
this is seymour close to the west and
this is the cold yard site we've just
been looking at
in the previous application
and this is another view of the site so
this is the site here moncton street
along here and you can see its
relationship with
the moncton recreation
ground to the south of the site
um as has been mentioned the site is not
within the settlement of moncton but it
is adjacent to
the village
and it as you can see it has
developmental built form and landscaping
along at least three or the majority of
free potentially three and a half of its
sides so along the monkton street
frontage
a long list site here the fox hunter
site which does then wrap around to the
rear of the site as well
so i'm going to take you down
some photographs of the site so we can
just have a look at it
as it stands today so this is the
access to the site
and 102 moncton street to the right
this is again enough review of the
access
this is 96 mountain street and again 102
and this is actually
looking the house is to fronting moncton
street so we're standing within the site
at this point and you can see fox
hunter's uh sight wrapping around on the
eastern boundary
so this is enough a view of the site and
looking across again to the eastern
boundary
and you can see the
units in the foxhunter site
this photograph is showing the southern
boundary of the site
so the rear of the site
and you can see the spotlights and
lighting here is actually lights on the
recreation ground
so we're walking around and looking at
the western boundary of the site here
so that's the site uh the boundary that
butts so the coal yards site we just
considered members have just looked at
and we can see this again some debris of
the properties fronting monkton street
and then this is looking standing in the
site looking up the access road
towards moncton street
as mentioned
this is an outline application with only
access to be considered
whilst the details of the schema are not
to be considered at this time a series
of parameter plans have been submitted
and this is the land use parameter plan
so you can see here the blue areas which
is the areas that would be developed
and you can see they are fairly
centrally located within the site
with open space
and landscaping proposed around the
edges of the site
so moving on to the building heights
plan
the main
developer area would consist of
two-story dwellings with potentially
some
2.5
two and a half story dwellings in this
sort of central location here
and this is considered being keeping
with the surrounding development monctum
which is a mix of bungalows and
mainly two-story dwellings
the movement access plan here
it again shows the developer areas the
open space around the site
it highlights the central sort of spine
road running through the development
secondary roads running off and also the
dotty lines here
are pedestrian routes and footpaths
this is an illustrative master plan for
the site showing how 49 dwellings could
be accommodated
on the site based on the parameter plans
that we have just looked at
the developer developer ball area of the
site is some 1.7 hectares
which with 49 dwellings would give a
density of 29 dwellings per hectare
this is considered to be a pro an
appropriate density for a village
location and similar to other recent
developments and developments that have
been approved in moncton and alpha fanuc
villages
members will be aware that this scheme
does include some highway off-site
highway works and we'll have a look at
those over the next few slides
so we just to give
some
bearings again this is the access to the
site here
the access to the cold yard site in this
location here
and obviously moncton street running
across with the school in this location
here
so this plan actually does show all the
highway works that are being proposed
and the work's all accommodated on
highway land
but it is quite a complicated plan so we
have broken it down so you can see it
more clearly in individual parts as on
some next slides
so this plan shows the proposed footpath
here from the access to the application
site that will be installed and run
westwards towards the school
it also shows the giveaway that would be
located
in front of the school or adjacent to
the school here the build out and then
the narrowing of the carriageway to a
single
lane here and then
it widening out again and becoming
two-way
in this location
these plans have been at the request of
kcc highways updated to reflect
and show the access the cold yard site
here so all the highway plans you'll see
will have that access
shown on them
so this is the photograph shows the
school and the current high
current road layout in front of it
you can see the bus stop and the bus
there's also the bus stop on the
opposite side of the road these bus
stops will remain in place but they will
be slightly moved in terms of the
highway works
this photo
is further along the road to the east
this is access the cold yard site we've
just looked at here in front of the cars
on the right hand side
and
then
pretty much adjacent to sort of the
school
edge of the school wall would be where
the giveaway
sign would be for entrance for cars
waiting for this to enter the single
story carriage single lane carriageway
single story so this is the plan
the highway plan of that so you can see
this is the access cold yard site
the school is here and you can see the
giveaway
and sign there so it's almost level with
the edge of the school
and you can see the build out and the
entrance to
there's a single carriageway
element that's being proposed
this photo is then moving further east
again away from the school towards the
access to the site
and this is 108 moncton street which
members will note
does directly in its current state about
um the highway
this proposal shows the highway
works proposal on the area the
photograph you just looked at so this
isn't the number 108
and the school is here with the giveaway
proposed giveaway
so along this
area the road will actually be narrowed
so this is the bit that's the single
story bit widening out again to
a single lane widening out again to two
lanes
as you move further east
and but you will also note
the sort of dotted pink purple line
that's the footpath so
it would actually be an improvement for
number 108 will not sit
up but in the highway it would have that
benefit of the footpath
um
taking away from the highway
so this photograph is shows the edge of
the access to the application site and
is looking westwards towards the school
the carriageway here will be slightly
widened
in the vicinity of where these cars are
currently parked
it will be its high actual highway land
that will be incorporated to make the
road formally wider and it does not
affect the boundary treatments of any of
the properties that you see on the right
hand side
so this plan shows the access to the
site
so on the bottom right here
and the area where the road will be wide
which is this element here
members should note the proposed high
works have gone for a safety audit they
have been tested for htvs buses
large and small cars trailers carrying
mobile
homes refuse vehicles and um
farm machinery and tractors and those
sort of agricultural vehicles that might
come through the village
um kcc highways have been consulted on
the application and raised no objection
to the proposal
for post-highway work subject to the
imposition of conditions
and it is also noted that proposed works
are almost identical to that proposed in
the previous application
and there was no highway reason for
refusal
either from the council or indeed when
the appeal was dismissed
um
so as mentioned peripherally
the site is within the countryside for
planning purposes
but the site is enclosed
essentially on three sides by built form
so you have houses fronting moncton
street
we have the fox hunter
park that wraps around the east and
the southern boundary and we have
the development of the
cold yard building site
to the
west boundary
but then as we've heard we've just
granted consent for houses on that site
as well
so it is not considered that there would
be a major visual impact
from long distance views of the
development of this site
there would be impacts um but there
would mainly be in limited close
proximity
uh of the site and as and essentially
from the dire if you're standing in the
direct view of the access to the site
you'd obviously be able to see it is
developed rather than as it currently
stands as a field
in terms of drainage the scheme proposes
that wastewater
would go to the public sewer in moncton
street um it's been acknowledged that
this is likely to require a pumping
station on the site but that would be a
matter for the reserve matters
submission
in terms of surface water a sud scheme
is proposed including an attenuation
basin which is located in the
illustrative master plan in this
location
excuse me the environment agency
southern water kcc is the lead local
flood authority and also the river
stower drainage board
have all reviewed the application and
raised no objections to the drainage
works subject to conditions
moving on to ecology the application was
supported by an ecological appraisal and
as a result of that appraisal was
identified as a reptile study should be
carried out and that was done
kcc have reviewed both those documents
and raise again raise no objections
subject to a number of conditions which
relate to the mitigation of those
reports being carried out on site and
also ecological enhancements coming
forward as part of the application
and finally as mentioned at the
beginning of the meeting a section 106
legal agreement has been received from
the applicant and has been signed and
sealed by the council
this secures the 30 affordable housing
the requested contributions
which include the sam
so on that basis officers consider that
the benefits of the proposal
outweigh
the harm that would be caused from it in
terms of loss of countryside lost a loss
of agricultural land
and it is therefore recommended that the
application
be
approved thank you chair
uh thank you very much annabelle
i recommend that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second
oh second nature thank you council
common cook
members do you wish to debate
council ghana
thank you
yeah i
i have some very similar
concerns to the previous
application we discussed
and approved uh majority wise
um treating these both in isolation
one's been treated and approved we now
come to this one
um
i can't
i find it very difficult even to
consider
approving this this is going to have
a major impact on the village of moncton
as has been um described by the two
residents and by the parish councillor
it's it's a total
transformation of the village on land
that doesn't need and countryside land
that doesn't need to be developed
um
it was rejected by us at a previous
planning committee meeting and rejected
by
that was uphold by the plan inspector
and i have to say i find
it quite distasteful
that the zeal with which this has
resubmitted and it's in an attempt
to exploit
our
um
the tilted balance in favor of
developments as a result of not
funny district council not us
not delivering the housing test but on
developers other developers not actually
building the houses that they've they've
been given permission for
and i really
i mean i do
try and i came into this i'm pretty
determined as always
but there is no way that i can will i
can't imagine a way that anyone here is
going to persuade me
that i should support
this um
awful
development on countryside that will
totally transform this village thank you
thank you council ghana councillor keane
[Applause]
thank you
um i know kcc have not highlighted any
problems with the the roads and traffic
and that but i just find that really
hard to believe that this amount of
traffic is not going to have a very
negative effect i noticed one of the
comments i think from the moncton parish
council the safety audit was carried out
over a one-hour period in july this does
not reflect the diverging traffic
conditions during the day especially
during school drop off and pick up times
and i cannot see
how the narrowing to one lane is is is
going to not cause huge traffic problems
so i'm very dubious about that
thank you council kane council right
thank you mr chairman um i think
i i did have a lot written down here but
a lot of it's already been said which i
i totally support
um
there is already some considerable
development on that site
and
this this is a piece of land which it
isn't just it isn't just surface water
in the winter it regularly floods
it has minimal access to
mountain street and what i'd all all it
will do is add to the problems in
mountain
those i don't know what time they they
did their traffic survey because i can't
believe that a fire engine a big lorry
and whatever could could go down that
road without interrupting the traffic
i feel that this does not give
any indication of any benefits to the
area
and could i um just as a matter of
interest could i ask you when when this
went through the flood management
committee
have you got a date please
sorry the flood management
i do not know well i'll then i can't i
won't be supporting this application i
really would like to know what date that
was that that assessment was done
thank you
sir
i can't i can't comment on the planning
but i do will comment on kcc which we
too are
i can't believe that kcc can i report on
that
i can't believe that they expect this
traffic to go past it school
is
on kcc
i'd like to have much more information
on that road that's going to affect the
whole village i've got nothing against
the planning because i can't comment on
that but kcc which we are i don't know
how that part got through thank you
uh thank you council
in fairness i i
totally understand your kcc
uh but we're tdc tonight okay it's
planning committee of authentic council
which i'm sure you're aware of um yeah
thank you i just just want to clarify
that as the highways work so in terms of
the the the safety order that's been
carried out and looked at by kcc
obviously when it comes to demonstrating
harm to the highway network it's going
to be the basis of evidence and indeed
it's got to be demonstrated
um so this was looked at in the previous
application for the same arrangement of
the giveaway
a single lane and a new pedestrian
access uh sorry pedestrian footwear on
the south of london street um the
application previously on that basis was
not refused on impact on highways but it
was considered by the inspector who
looked at the fact that the highway
authority didn't object the council
didn't object and nor on the basis of
the information for had it been
demonstrated that the current the
arrangement proposed was dangerous or
the existing relationship is dangerous
and indeed consider there was a moderate
benefit to the highway so i think in
terms of um potentially objecting to the
application on the basis of a concern
regardless the highway arrangement would
be unreasonable for this council to take
so that's my advice to you members thank
you
uh thank you ian um
then i would object on the change to the
character and appearance of the
area
thank you are there any other members
wish to cancel david
thank you chair um i
hear what everyone has to say and to
some degree i do agree that it would
change the character of the village but
i can't accept that
that the council looking to balance the
books we are addressing a genuine
housing need
this is 49 homes with 30 affordable
housing which we desperately need and i
think that has to be considered in all
applications thank you
thank you council ghana you wish to come
back
yeah i just wanted to mention one other
thing um
separate what i've said before i think
it needs to be
stated that if i think it was mentioned
that a new pumping station
would be required to cope with
with these houses and if we're
going to be approving planning
applications on the basis of southern
water
providing us with a new pumping station
um bearing in mind that if the
effectiveness of their existing public
stations i would have further
concerns to add to my previous ones
thank you
thank you i'm going to ask him again to
come back home
just to confirm in terms of mitigating
the impact of drainage on this site
obviously there are other requirements
under other legislation which would
require the functioning of the proposed
pumping station so in terms of
considering the track record of southern
water
then i would suggest that that is his
isn't he's given given very limited
weight if any at all in the
determination of this application thank
you
thank you council hopkinson
thanks joe can i clarify is there a
difference of opinion about whether this
is allocated in the local plan on the
basis of you know the interrupting
whether or not this is within the
countryside or not
i mean let's get the office of view on
that
um no it's it's it's outside the urban
confines in relation to the village
confines of of moncton so it is in the
countryside
yes carry out
so yeah so
it's not it's not allocated land in the
local plan then
thank you for that uh i can't see any
other members so i'm going to put this
to you
um
i put it forward to you that this is for
a approval for those in favor please
show their hands
for approval
those against
abstentions
okay
that has fallen uh so bear with me a
moment please
please
which was uh obviously refused on a
specific reason um so that reason looked
at um the impact um from the loss of the
countryside outside the urban confines
of the
plan where the need
environmental benefits and specifically
uh reference to the old
outlined um it was also a country so
that's that's sp 26. um as also being
uh contrary to sp 24. um it does
reference sp01 and sp01 is the
strategic policy for housing development
in the district
now as outlined in the report
that policy is considered by the mppf
as out of date because the council has
failed to meet the housing test
um
however in the inspector's decision
uh that impact
from the loss of bessemer's first island
was outweighed individually outweighed
by the benefits of housing development
okay so the inspector didn't refuse it
because there was also the best most
versatile agricultural land um it was
refused because of the loss of
to the landscape as well as the special
strategy of the district
so
in terms of proposing a motion to refuse
the application if members are so minded
it would be
on the basis of what's been discussed in
the previous appeal decision
um
the the reason for refusal um we would
suggest does not include sp01
because that
is deferred by uh
issues that have been discussed this
evening um so that would be the loss of
the countryside uh the landscape harm to
the
star masters landscape area um again
where the development where the need for
development has not been demonstrated
that way they need to protect the
countryside and the harm resulted from
the loss is not sufficiently outweighed
by economic social environmental
benefits country policies sp 24 which is
the development of the policy and sp 26
which is the last character report of
the local plan of 2020
uh paragraph for the mppf
thank you uh thank you
members uh you heard what mr universe
has said there and
he does have things written down which i
don't so um
that i will put us a proposal to you um
counselor
paul
being yeah and defunct causes silicone
still exists
but the particular paragraph
says that any policy that is looking to
effectively restrict where the supply of
housing goes in the district um that
policy has is considered out of date if
the council either can't demonstrate a
five-year supply of housing land or
indeed that they we don't meet the
housing delivery test to a sufficient
degree so the issue is that that policy
doesn't have any weight which is why as
outlined the tilted balance applies or
members consider that there is
demonstrable harm that in your view
outweighs the benefits from the scheme
um but it doesn't necessarily mean that
the ref the reference in our opinion
should be removed sp01 and actually
focus on fact this is development of the
countryside and it results in harm in
your view to the landscape character
area which is sp 24
and sp26
you have that count some more
oh
okay well once again i'm coming back to
um
mr levinson did so
um so the the application would
therefore be the motion in front of
members is for refusal uh the proposal
by virtue of its location would result
in the loss of countryside and harm to
the landscape character area outside the
identified urban confines of the local
plan
um
and um it's that the development has not
been uh demonstrated by a way the need
to protect the countryside and the
homicide for the loss is not sufficient
therefore outweighed by economic and
social benefits contrary to policies sp
24 and sp 26 the local plan 2020
and and the national party policy
framework
thank you and it has been proposed and
secondly once again put it to yourselves
you you've heard what mr livingston said
there could i have a show of hands
please if you agree
against
abstentions
that is carried thank you members thank
you very much
all right um that concludes public
speaking for this meeting i will now
call a call upon
el clark james
to read out the remaining planning
application
if
i'll hold fire a moment why people are
leaving i think
stop not yet
next to the council
just a few more few moments
because it was outweighed because it
benefits the housing ladies gentlemen
right
so that concludes public speaking at the
meeting
i will now call upon the clerk um james
to my right here to read out the
remaining plan applications if there's
any member
who wishes to reserve the limited size
a little bit of hush please
haven't finished yet
um a few minutes to go
if a member wishes to reserve an
application that he reads out will they
please call out
as he reads
james
thank you chair so there are two
applications remaining from the schedule
and which is 5b for approval 7 guilford
lawn ramsgate
and 5c again for approval which is the
kent innovation center and it reached
business park millennium way
okay i don't see any hands
in the air so could i have a proposer
that they are moved for approval both
those items please
because of coleman cook secondary
council keene uh do you all agree
thank you members
okay
move on now to uh
you can't wait can you
hey
agenda item
six
uh number 43 queen bertha avenue
birchington uh it says politely down
here councillor keane but i could say
something else i won't know
um
councillor keane has left the meeting
because um
as we all know if
a councillor is involved in an
application they are asked to leave so
um
the plan obviously will now outline the
report
which is meet emma
thank you emma
um so this is a lawful um
development certificate application for
a proposed single story rear extension
so as you've heard it's come before
members as
the councillor is the applicant
um
here's the application site in this area
here
and the extension is
to the rear on the left-hand side
of
the property shall we i'm actually gone
[Music]
not showing up sorry it's not showing up
on the screen but it's on the left hand
side is the rear extension to the
property
sorry i'm not much lucky so this is the
existing elevations
and then this is the proposed so the top
right hand side is that root is the rear
extension
and from the rear and the bottom is the
side view of the rear extension
so the extension measures um 2.5 meters
deep and 6.7 meters wide and 3.7 meters
high so
the um
the consideration is whether it complies
with the criteria as set out within the
general permitted development order
um
that requires that an extension could be
no more than three meters in depth and
no more than four meters in height so
the size of it does comply and in terms
of the materials it is rendered to match
the existing property which is a
requirement of a condition of um class a
and therefore it is considered by us to
be permitted development so it's
recommended for approval as a pd
thank you emma i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted could i have
my chair please second i'll second that
too
this would be interesting to any member
wish to debate
no
okay
that's been carried thank you very much
oh yes do you agree i'm sorry
it's late normally in bed
sorry members
agree
yes any against